Tim Ferriss: Hello, boys and girls, ladies
and germs.
This is Tim Ferriss.
Welcome to another episode of The Tim Ferriss
Show.
My guest today is Todd McFarlane.
Todd is an Emmy- and Grammy-winning director,
producer, and creator of one of the world's
best-selling comic books, Spawn.
He is best known to many comic book fans for
his work as the artist on The Amazing Spider-Man,
for which he co-created Marvel's top villain,
Venom.
Todd is the CEO of Todd McFarlane Productions,
McFarlane Toys, one of the US's top action
figure manufacturers, and McFarlane Films.
He is also a co-founder of Image Comics, which
debuted Spawn in 1992, selling 1.7 million
copies of the first issue.
In 1997, Spawn was made into an Emmy award-winning
animated series on HBO and a live-action feature
film that grossed more than $100 million.
In 2019, Todd made history with Spawn #301,
earning the Guinness World Record for the
longest-running creator-owned superhero comic
book series.
You can find him online, Instagram @toddmcfarlane,
Twitter @Todd_McFarlane, and Facebook, liketoddmcfarlane.
Todd, it is nice to see you again.
Todd McFarlane: Yeah, thanks for having me
back, Tim.
Appreciate it.
Tim Ferriss: And I wanted to close the Marvel
chapter, and I'll just explain for folks who
are hearing this episode first.
We recorded a first episode, which laid a
lot of the groundwork, your background, established
your personality, which I'm sure will come
through in this episode as well, and early
days in comics, many of the key decisions,
negotiations, your magical capacity, with
your camel bladder, to inflict negotiating
superiority on your adversaries, and many
other things.
And I thought we would put a pin in the Marvel
chapter by talking about Stan Lee.
And perhaps you could just explain who Stan
Lee is and how you first developed a relationship
with him.
Todd McFarlane: Probably most people who've
been paying attention to movies already know
who Stan is, but Stan is sort of the grandfather
of being one of the co-creators of all these
superhero characters that we all know by name.
Right?
So if we go back, when Marvel first began
in the early '60s, he was a writer, and he
helped create characters like The Fantastic
Four, Spider-Man, Iron Man, The Hulk, Doctor
Strange, Black Panther, and the X-Men, and
on and on and on and on.
To put it in perspective really, when he passed
away a few years back, to me — and I think
a lot of people sort of said the same thing
— you put him in the same category as somebody
like Walt Disney, in terms of the global impact
that his characters had.
Not necessarily him as a person, but that
his characters had.
Stan was a comic book guy for a lot of years
and then eventually moved out to California
in the '70s and, odd as it is, really sort
of became a big-time celebrity when the movies
came around.
And he started making cameos in the Marvel
movies.
And he started that when he was 85.
So most people don't begin a new career when
they're 85.
Stan did, and he did it.
So my quick sort of meeting with him, first
time I meet him, I'm about 16, 17 years old,
a Canadian kid in Florida, going to a baseball
camp.
And I happened to stay overnight, before we're
going to catch a plane, go back home, in a
Holiday Inn.
And there was a sign that said down the hall
there was a comic book convention.
I go down the hall, and Stan Lee — again,
he's not the famous celebrity at this point.
We're talking now about the mid '70s.
And Stan Lee was there.
And to me, he was like The Pope because anybody
who's ever read any Marvel comic books, at
the top of every Marvel comic books at that
time said, "Stan Lee Presents."
He was in every book, "Stan Lee Presents,"
every comic book I got.
So I'm like, "Wow, there's Stan Lee, the guy
who presents every Marvel comic book."
And I walked up to him.
I wanted to break into comics.
And I asked him, "Hey, Mr. Lee, is it okay
if I ask you a couple questions?"
And without hesitation, he pulled a chair
right next to him, and he said, "Sit down,
son.
Ask me what you want."
And he let me sit next to him for about five
hours, peppering him with questions.
Now, again, he didn't have a big, giant lineup
because like I said, he hadn't hit his celebrity
status that would come decades later.
But just that he just said, "Here, sit next
to me.
You got questions?"
And so when I went home to Canada, that was
one of the moments where I went, "Yeah, I'm
going to really drive and do this."
My next encounter with him, now, fast forward,
I actually do break into comics.
I climbed the rank-and-file that you and I
talked about in our first interview.
I even get to do Spider-Man, which is sort
of the corporate icon of Marvel Comics.
That puts me on the map, and I set sales records
with those books.
And then a bunch of us quit, and we start
Image Comics.
And I end up doing a series of videos with
Stan in 1992, '93 and sort of rekindling
a professional relationship.
Tim Ferriss: Todd, I'm sorry to interrupt.
What were those videos that you did with Stan?
What was the content or the intention of those
videos that you did with Stan around '92,
'93?
Todd McFarlane: Most of them are up on YouTube.
They were just Stan and I sitting there, and
he did it with a couple of my other, fellow
artists.
And you just sat at a table, and you talked
art, or you drew, and you were talking through
your drawing like, "How do you create characters?"
Tim Ferriss: Cool.
Todd McFarlane: "Why does that guy look like
that?"
Right?
And it was just sort of almost a how-do-you-do-it
sort of videos that were there.
Tim Ferriss: Did he not view that as competitive,
since you guys had split off to be Image at
that point?
Todd McFarlane: No, because Stan was very
entrepreneurial himself.
He was almost an ambassador for Marvel at
this point and doing his own stuff.
So the interviews and the videotapes were
sort of under an umbrella that was part of
his own camp.
Tim Ferriss: Ah, I see.
Got it.
Todd McFarlane: I think they were giving him
a salary to be a good steward, going around,
but he wasn't writing any books at that point.
Tim Ferriss: Got it.
Yeah, he was like the professor emeritus of
Marvel.
Todd McFarlane: That's exactly what he was.
And let me also say, he was very, very generous
in terms of encouraging us, even though he
knew that our books were going to be in direct
competition with Marvel.
Because again, he was a creative guy.
And having been around Stan as much as I have
been, his superpower to me, besides he created
all these characters that none of us will
ever come close to — I mean, I've got Spawn.
He's got like a hundred Spawns.
And I saw it over and over and over, in all
the times I was with him, within 20 seconds.
When you have a big lineup, and people are
coming for autographs, you literally have
20 seconds with each individual.
And he would make people feel important, special,
and unique in that 20 seconds.
And then he would reset for the next person.
And he would do it all over again for thousands
of people.
Right?
They felt like that was the best 20 seconds
of Stan's day, even though he was giving it
to every single person.
And I saw this when I was 16, when I was sitting
with him for the first time.
But I just kept becoming more and more aware
of this is how you treat the public because
the public, without them, without the fans,
we have no careers.
We are basically self-indulging in our basements.
Right?
You can have ideas, but if nobody is consuming
them — I go to shows, and people go, "Todd,
why do you say thank you to me?
We should be thanking you."
It's like, "You give me money.
Every product you buy, you give me money.
You put food on my family's table.
If you get something out of me, cool.
But I must thank you, too, because I have
a career because of your existence."
Which is why it's odd, Tim, that I've run
into enough celebrities, whether it's sports,
music, movies, TV, whatever it is, and some
are a little off-put by their fans.
Tim Ferriss: Mm-hmm.
Todd McFarlane: They are the reason we exist.
And part of it was looking at people like
Stan Lee, I've never been put off by people
wanting to ask questions or whatever else.
And I've had reporters ask me, especially
during the whole before comic books were sort
of a cool, hip thing, "Todd, what's the dumbest
question people ask?
Is it like Trekkie conventions?"
Here's the answer.
"There is no dumb question.
You know why?
Because whoever is asking it, it's important
to them.
And if it's important to them, it's important
for me to answer it.
So even if the question may seem silly to
you — because they want to know who would
win, The Hulk or Thor, in a fight — it's
important to that individual.
So I'm going to give them as good an answer
as I can, and I'm not going to look down my
nose at them like you are."
Anyway Stan is involved in a cameo when the
first Iron Man movie comes out, and the studio,
Paramount, says, "Hey, we're going to give
Stan his own movie premiere."
And they did it in Vegas.
Somebody phones me up and says, "Hey, Todd,
can you come and be the MC of that thing?
There's going to be a dinner" or whatever
else.
And I'm like, "Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Sure."
So I come.
I get up there.
I say all the gracious and true things about
Stan Lee that I believe.
And everything goes cool.
And at the end, Stan comes up to me and says,
"Hey, thanks.
Thanks, young man.
That was quite wonderful."
Now, I'm like, "Oh, thanks, appreciate you
having me, Stan."
The next day, and here's where it happens,
the next day is I'm walking around the Vegas
hotel, and I see Stan, and he goes, "Todd.
Todd, hold us up.
Hold up.
Hold up."
And he comes running over, and he goes, "Oh,
my God.
You were wonderful last night.
You were amazing last night."
And I went, "No, no, no, you said that.
You said that to me, Stan."
And he goes, "No, I didn't.
I can't hear anymore.
I didn't hear a damn thing you said last night.
But what they do is that they record it, and
then I go to my room, and then I can actually
put on the headphones, and then I heard it.
It was wonderful."
Right?
He had just figured out how to be in public
with bad hearing and pull it off.
So after he hears me, I guess being kind and
a little charismatic, he says, "Todd, I go
to conventions almost every weekend.
Travel with me, and come with me around the
country, and you and I, let's team up."
Now, gracious offer.
"Stan, I've got a day job."
Right?
"So I can't.
I mean, I understand, Batman.
You would like me to be your Robin, and it's
very, very complimentary, but I've got to
do it."
But I said, "When I can, I will."
So I did.
From that point on, I did.
I've probably been up on stage with Stan more
than any human being on the planet.
We had this little shtick, and part of it
was at the beginning because, literally, Tim,
he could not hear.
He could not hear.
So what he needed was somebody who could hear
and then turn and slightly give him the question
or frame it in a way that made sense for a
comic book guy, where a lot of times, moderators
didn't know the comic book sort of lingo.
We just sort of had this weird kabuki dance
we were doing so that he could hear.
Now, it came to a crescendo one time, where
we were in San Diego, and he was up on stage.
I mean, it was a big room, with probably 5,000
people in.
And they put up the big giant screen so the
people at the very back can at least look
at the video.
Tim Ferriss: Right.
Todd McFarlane: Right?
The video screen.
And Stan was in the middle.
And I usually sit next to him, but I go, "No.
Stan, this is your gig.
I'm going to be over here on the podium, just
talking."
We start doing our thing.
Boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom,
boom.
And next thing you know, I'm talking.
and I'm sort of not paying attention because
I'm looking at the audience, and then I turn,
and Stan is literally six inches on my flank.
And then I look up at the screen, because
the screen wasn't mobile.
The camera was fixed.
The stage was empty because he had scooted
so far over.
So I look at him, under my breath, go, "Stan,
you're offscreen.
You're not on TV.
All the people in the back..."
But he's going, "Todd, I can't hear a damn
thing."
Let me tell you, eventually he got a hearing
aid, and all of a sudden, the heavens opened
up, and he was like, "Oh, my God, Todd, I
should have done this years ago."
Even once he got the hearing aid, we still
did our shtick, doing it.
And there's a photo that, to me, is one of
the dearest photos that I have in my collection,
outside of my family.
We were in Phoenix, which is where I live.
And we were doing our thing.
It was a little, small convention here, and
we were up on stage.
This is post his wife passing away.
That mattered in his life, because, I mean,
I was there.
I got to bring him up on stage when he got
his Hollywood Walk of Fame star and at the
Chinese Mann Theater.
Right?
I was sort of like his guy to bring him up
on stage.
So I was there for a couple important moments
of him.
And I'd gone up on stage with him so many
times.
He had so much energy.
And as we walked up the stairs at that one
at Phoenix, he turned to me and said, "Todd,
you do most of the talking.
I don't want be here."
It was the first time ever that I didn't hear
enthusiasm out of that man.
Right?
And I mean, he was already old.
And I saw it, when he arrived, that he looked
as old as I ever saw him.
Anyways, we did our interview.
I always used to take these selfies.
I got all these cool pictures of me and him
taking selfies because he never understood
what a selfie was.
So he's always, right, jammed — his face
jammed into the lens.
So I got these cool, awesome photos.
In the green room before we went up, he used
to take a nap because he was in his 90s.
He used to pace himself.
So I've got all these cool pictures of me
making faces around him while he's napping.
Right?
So I'm going to put a whole book out.
It's going to be Nap Time With Stan.
I'm going to publish someday.
But he walked up there, and when he said those
words, it was a dagger in my heart.
And we did our interview.
We took the selfie.
We walked offstage, and that was the last
time he was ever on stage.
And he shortly passed away.
Right?
And I kicked myself because you have a couple
regrets.
That was one, that I wish we knew that was
going to be the last time that he was going
to be on a stage in his lifetime because we
would've sent him off with a better applause
than we did that day.
Anyways, like I said, I was fortunate.
Even after he stopped going to shows, I was
one of the few people that was allowed to
be in his house because there was infighting
amongst some fiefdoms around him, like I said,
once his wife went away.
But the last time I went and saw him, I go,
"Hey, Stan, how you doing, bud?"
And he said, "Todd, I can't see.
I can't hear.
I can't go to shows.
And Joanie," which is his wife, "and Joanie's
not here.
I just want to be with Joanie."
Right?
His two things was he had the love of his
life, his wife, almost married 70 years, those
two people, 70 years.
And when she left, you can imagine, he lost
his soulmate.
And then the only thing he had left was the
conventions.
And once his hearing and his eyesight went
completely, couldn't go to that.
Both the things that were sort of important
to him left, and he sort of broke down at
the end.
Here's the thing.
We're talking about a guy who, up to the age
of 93, was doing cartwheels up on stage.
We never allowed him to be old.
Tim Ferriss: Do you mean literally doing cartwheels?
No, you just mean energetically.
Todd McFarlane: No, no.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, I'm saying 93, he got up there.
You throw him a question, and he just went.
At 93 —
Tim Ferriss: 93.
Todd McFarlane: — he was at the top —
Tim Ferriss: It's incredible.
Todd McFarlane: — of his game.
94.
He passed away at 95.
he was still at the top of his game onstage.
And part of it was, he was so immortal to
us that we never acknowledged that he was
in his 90s.
We just thought he was like some 50-year-old
guy with a lot of energy.
Eventually, time came, and he had to leave
us.
Tim Ferriss: Todd, you spent so much time
with Stan, and you observed so many things,
picked up on so many things, firsthand and
then as an observer.
For instance, the energy that he could summon,
the focus that he could summon to be with
each person for 20 seconds and then reset,
which is really a skill and a talent —
Todd McFarlane: It is.
Tim Ferriss: — and very taxing.
So that is extremely impressive, in and of
itself.
Are there any other lessons or learnings that
you took from Stan or things that still come
up that lead you to sort of reminisce about
sort of the University of Stan, as it were,
spending time with him?
Todd McFarlane: I'll comment on two things.
Number one, the Stan that was onstage was
the same man offstage.
It wasn't a put-on.
Right?
I mean, I've got recording.
He used to let me record him.
And he'd be in the taxi and pick me up at
the airport, and the whole drive from the
airport to the hotel, he'd be like, "Why is
Todd here?
I don't like it when the good-looking guys
are here."
And he would just do this whole thing, where
he was just jabbing me the whole drive, because
we did a lot of it up on stage.
So again, it wasn't put on.
But I remember.
And here's the last thing I'll say.
I remember dozens of times of him being in
the green room as we're getting ready to go
up on stage or something, and he would turn
to me, And it would just be him and I. And
he would go, "Todd, isn't this wonderful?
Isn't this great?
I'm having a great time this weekend."
He goes, "Who would've thought, guys like
you and I — we're nobodies, and look at
this.
We're having the best..."
And so what I'm saying is that the reason
he was able to summon that energy is because
he was getting as much out of the audience
as they were getting out of him.
It was chicken noodle for his soul when he
went to the shows, which is why when his wife
was sick, Joanie, she said, "Don't stop going
to the shows.
Even after I'm gone, don't.
You need it."
Right?
To his credit, he did.
He kept going.
Yeah, he liked being there.
And so it wasn't a put-on.
Like I said, I've been around a lot of celebrities,
and I think, in all honesty, Tim, of all the
celebrities I've been around — obviously,
I haven't climbed the mountain of a lot of
others.
But of all the celebrities I've been around,
and all the time I spent, if I was to pick
one person to write the book How to Interact
With Your Fans, by far, Stan Lee's the guy
who would do the "how to do it."
Tim Ferriss: Amazing.
Stan.
I mean, I remember, as a collector, seeing
the masthead as a little kid, right, and then
even into my early teens.
Todd McFarlane: The "Stan Lee Presents" masthead.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, of course.
Yes.
Todd McFarlane: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: Stan Lee.
Correct me if I'm getting this wrong, but
the voice that you actually impersonated really
well, for people who don't know, would come
on some of the early cartoon adaptations.
Todd McFarlane: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: And his voice would come on,
and I would see that every morning, eating
my cereal, getting ready to go to school.
So Stan Lee, for me, also had this iconic,
Pope-like importance as a little kid in a
childhood experience where that doesn't really
exist.
It's like, "Who is this mythic Stan Lee?"
Todd McFarlane: I'll tell you another little
silly story.
We're in the trailer — again, the equivalent
of green room — waiting to go up on stage.
And I was sitting with Stan, and they were
talking about him doing his cameos.
He'd done three or four cameos in a row.
And I went, "Oh, yeah."
And I don't really go to the Marvel movie,
so I don't know.
The next one coming up was Thor.
The commercials were running.
And I kept seeing the commercial.
And he had short hair.
Thor had short hair.
And to me, I'm like, "What?
Thor's got long hair.
That's weird."
And so anyways, I'm talking to Stan, we're
in the trailer, and I go, "Oh, you've got
to do some more cameos.
Oh, yeah.
And the Thor, what did you do on the Thor
one?"
And he goes, "Let me think.
I'm trying to remember.
Oh, yeah, I think I was the barber."
And I went, "What?"
He goes, "Yeah, I do this scene where I'm
the barber."
And I go, "So what do you do?"
He goes, "I cut Thor's hair."
"Hold a sec.
I've been seeing this commercial.
He's got short hair.
You cut his hair?"
And he's like, "Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I cut his hair.
It's this weird thing where I've got this
big blade, and I've got bad eyesight, and
they're pinning him down."
And I'm going, "Oh, my gosh, that's the coolest
thing."
And then I just went, "Oh, man, if we only
had a pair of scissors, we could reenact that."
He goes, "I'll get a pair of scissors, Todd."
And he actually went and found a pair of scissors,
and then he literally reenacted — I videotaped
it — where I'm Thor, and they're holding
me down, and he's saying his lines, and he's
like going — he's doing all of it.
Like I said, we're we're about to go on stage,
but he's still just goofing around.
Right?
Someday I'll release it.
That is arguably the best piece of video I
have from Stan, because he was a very kind,
polite, gentle man in terms of his language,
if you will, when he was up on stage.
And I have the one where I recorded, where
he goes, "Todd, can I tell you something?"
Again, out of the blue.
"Can I tell you something?"
"Yeah, Stan.
You can say whatever you want."
"Do you know what the most flexible word is
in the English dictionary, that has the most
ways you can use it?"
And I went, "No, Stan."
"Fuck."
And I went, "What?"
I don't even think I ever heard him even say
"damn" up to this point.
And I'd been around him a lot.
And it sort of shocked me.
Right?
And I went, "Pardon?"
"Yeah, Todd.
Fuck."
And then he went on a dissertation of how
you can use that word as a noun, a pronoun,
an adjective, and gave examples of all them.
It was like a school teacher sort of doing
a classic masterclass in how to use a word
more than once.
It just happened to be that word.
So maybe —
Tim Ferriss: Wow.
Todd McFarlane: — someday that audio will
come out.
Tim Ferriss: Well, it seems like, in maybe
the appendices of the How to Interact With
Your Fans book that he would author, you would
have How to Enjoy Life and Not Complain as
the supplemental materials.
He seems like he was very good at enjoying
life, pausing, not getting swept up in all
the superficial nonsense, but stopping you
and saying, "Isn't this great?
Let's look at this for a second.
Isn't this amazing?"
It seems like he was able to really harness
his appreciation in a way that maybe fed him
and allowed him to get to his mid-90s still
doing the metaphoric cartwheels on stage.
That's something that comes across in the
stories.
Todd McFarlane: I think Stan, he comes from
the school of those of us who believe our
15 minutes of fame is just about over every
day we wake up.
We always —
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Todd McFarlane: — think tomorrow is the
day where they're going to understand that
we're imposters and that there's way more
important people that are more skilled, that
have more to say.
And all of a sudden you go to your next show,
and there's another group of people, and you
go, "Wow, I guess it's going to last one more
day."
Right?
And you keep going.
And you're thankful for it.
Right?
Tim Ferriss: Mm-hmm.
Todd McFarlane: Again, at some point, once
you know that you're fortunate, that's okay.
I mean at my end, I think there's a little
bit of Canadiana in it.
I was born in Canada.
I saw people like Steve Nash and Wayne Gretzky,
my big personal hero, sort of act like gentlemen,
even though they were superstars.
And I think part of it is, and I'm maybe overstating
it, but when you're from Canada, you know
that the big brother is America, and that's
where all of the big action is.
And if you can get any attention, and you
can even in infiltrate down there, you always
are sort of looking over your flank, going,
"Eventually you're going to see that they
can just pick one of their own.
They don't need us."
Right?
And so you see that with a lot of comedians
that come from Canada and actors come from
Canada.
Stan sort of had a little bit of Canada, Canadian,
in him, where he was just like, "Enjoy it
while you can.
You don't know if it's going to be here tomorrow."
Like your health.
Tim Ferriss: It seems to me, or at least it
seemed to me when I was younger, and even
now in some respects, once a comic guy, always
a comic guy.
However, you have managed to branch out and
infiltrate all of these different areas.
And I don't even know how to put them in order.
So you've got McFarland Toys.
Right?
So let's just generically lay it out.
You've got toys, music, directing, TV, film.
What is the order of how you entered those
various things?
So you're forging new paths, setting records
at Image.
When did these things start to pop up, and
in what order?
Todd McFarlane: In all honesty, Tim, they're
a bit scattered.
So let's see if we can go through them real
fast.
Right?
Let's just talk first about how the toys come
to be, real quickly.
Okay?
We start Image Comics.
We talked about that in the last show.
Image Comics, the third largest comic book
company in North America.
Marvel, DC and then Image Comics.
If you ask who's three, that's us, for 30
years in a row.
And because of that, when we came out in 1992,
that was when we first came out, and Spawn
came out in 1992.
We're celebrating the 30th anniversary of
both those this year.
Spawn went to the top of the charts, right,
set sales records at top of the charts.
And I'm not saying for independent comic books.
I'm saying top of the charts for comic books.
It was ahead of every Marvel and every DC
comic book.
And so you can imagine, when you have something
at the top of a chart, then people in other
industries come around, and they start knocking
on your door.
And so people were coming and knocking on
my door going, "Oh, my God, Spawn is at the
top of the charts.
You want to do pajamas and pillowcases and
toothbrushes and all these..."
what they call ancillary merchandising.
And so all those phone calls were coming.
Now, I gently said, "No, no, no, no, no.
I understand you want to do pillowcases, but
have you read a Spawn comic book?"
It was like, "Well, no, but we see it's number
one."
"So, do you know he…"
Tim Ferriss: Wrong answer for Todd.
Todd McFarlane: Yeah.
"Do you know he's from the pit of Hell?"
Right?
And you can just see there's a hesitation.
They're going — so I go, "Why don't you
take a couple of the issues.
This character's from the pit of Hell.
Go read a couple, and then decide whether
you want to do pillowcases for kids that are
five years old."
Right?
Now, a bunch of them didn't follow up with
their phone calls after I sort of put their
nose in the product.
All they saw was that Spawn was ahead of Spider-Man
and Batman and Superman, so it must be super
awesome.
Right?
That was it.
That was all their homework was at that point.
Here's what I had in the back of my mind when
we left Marvel Comic Books and we helped start
Image Comics.
I wanted to build a foundation because I feel
that, metaphorically, if you can build a strong
foundation, just like in the real world, you
can put a skyscraper on a strong foundation.
How do we know?
Because they exist.
Right?
So the foundation to me was, could I do movies,
TV, video games, and toys?
Those were the four.
Those were the four corner stuff.
Tim Ferriss: Could you just repeat those four?
Todd McFarlane: I mean, just for me.
Just for me.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, for you.
Todd McFarlane: Right.
My foundations were going to be video games,
TV, movies, and toys because I felt that if
you could get your brand into those four corners,
then — and again, because I was playing
in the comic book world — then I could branch
out into these areas and plant some corners
and get people to go, "Oh."
And it's worked, because I know people who've
since say, "I know Spawn from HBO," not because
they've read the comic or bought the toys.
It was they saw it on HBO or wherever.
I don't really care.
Let me just tell you, Tim.
My attitude is building a business.
You build a house.
That's your business, and you put as many
doors on your house as possible, and you make
sure they're all unlocked all the time.
I don't care how they get into the house.
I don't care how they come to the party.
It's party central inside the house.
Right?
I don't care if they go, "Todd, man, I saw
you did that music video."
I don't care.
"Door's open.
Come on in, come on in, come on in."
I don't care how you got here.
I am not discriminating on a fan, because
the bigger your army is, the collective whole,
the better chance you have of then sending
out your message for the next thing that you're
about to do, and it might work.
So those were the four pillars.
And to go through them real quick, I made
a deal with the video games.
I made the deal with HBO, and we'll get back
to that, on the TV.
New Line Cinema, we made the deal with the
movie.
And then we got to the toys.
And all the Fortune 500, the public companies,
came to my door, and they all gave their presentation.
Some of them were pretty elaborate.
They had prototypes and everything.
At the end of it, I just go, "I don't think
they get it."
What I heard was they're going to do traditional
toys and put them in traditional places and
market them in traditional ways, which basically
meant they were going to put Spawn next to
Teletubbies and all their Disney product.
And I thought it was a recipe for failure.
And oh, by the way, if I gave it to them,
and it failed, then when it didn't work, which
I thought it wouldn't, they would hand me
my brand back, and it would be tainted.
How do I then pick up those pieces, when people
go, "Ah, it failed last time, Todd.
Why would we want now to dust it off and try
it again?"
So I never felt like I could get what I wanted.
And so you have to then ask the next question.
How hard is it to make my own choice?
That's it.
Right?
And sometimes it's out of anger.
I've started companies just because I got
pissed off.
It's because people think that what they're
doing is way, way more complicated than it
is.
Let me tell you something right now, Tim.
We've got the Image Comics and we do our own
comic books.
And you know what making comic books is at
its core?
Ink on paper, period, period, period, ink
on paper.
Toys are not that much different.
It is plastic in a shape.
And if you have the right mold, you can make
a shape.
How do I know?
Anybody who's kind of old that remembers this,
when we were kids, remember you used to get
these little trays and they're in the shape
of dinosaurs, and then you poured the jello
into it, and you put it in the fridge, and
then you flip it out, and all of a sudden
your jello looked like dinosaurs.
You know why?
Because that was what the mold looks like.
So toys are plastic in jello molds, essentially.
Little bit more details I'm leaving out.
But essentially, that's it.
So when I asked the question, "How do you
make toys?
How do you make comics?"
Let me tell you, the people in that industry,
the people that are the leaders in that industry
always want you to think that it's way more
complicated, always want you to think that
it's basically undoable, and will never, ever
sidestep, no matter how good your idea is,
to let you pass them.
If anything, they will intentionally try and
trip you as you're passing them, and tell
you it can't be done, can't do it, will hire
people away from it.
They'll tell you everything, "Stop rocking
the boat.
Why don't you just get along?"
Everything that you can possibly imagine.
Why?
They don't want competition.
So at some point you have to shut all that
stuff down and go, "I don't care if I sell
five, I'm good enough."
And it was my money.
Again, the whole thing, spend other people's
money, I disagree one hundred percent.
Spend your own money.
You know why?
Because nobody gets to tell you what to do.
If you want to go buy a car with polka dots
on it, and it's your money, do it, and drive
it with a smile on your face.
And if somebody doesn't like it, tell them
to buy their own damn car.
But the moment you take somebody's money,
and they get to tell you whether they like
the polka dots on the car or not.
And so I just go, "No."
I spent my own cash when I started the companies,
and I was fortunate because the comic books
were paying royalties.
Let me just tell you, I wasn't getting paid
a lot per page.
That's not what made me, just so everybody
knows, at the height of my career at Marvel,
I was making $125 per page.
That was the max they were paying me.
It was the royalties, I was getting a percentage
of the sales, and that was the magic of it.
It's what literally made us economically at
Image Comics because we were getting four
percent of the profits.
And when we went and started our own company,
guess what?
We were getting 100 percent.
Do the math, if you take a hundred, divide
it by four, if we were selling 1/25th the
amount of books that we were doing at Marvel,
we would make the same money.
And guess what, boys and girls?
We sold the same, in some cases, more than
we were selling at Marvel.
So we were then all of a sudden instantly
making 25 times more than we were overnight.
And that's a whole 'nother conversation.
Tim Ferriss: And you could use that to bankroll
the toy development, your piece of that?
Todd McFarlane: Correct.
I wasn't spending it, I wasn't buying fancy
cars, I wasn't doing anything.
I'm kind of a tight when you get right down
to it.
I was just putting it in a corner for rainy
days, or when I was going to get angry, because
I knew my personality.
So we started the toy company, and we came
out with the first toys.
Action figures at that point were 5.99 and
I priced mine at 6.99.
And here is the thing, if you're listening
to my voice, all the big companies came to
me and patted me on the back and went, "Little
boy, you can't sell a 6.99 toy.
They're 5.99."
Here's the answer: of course you can.
Here's how you sell a 6.99 toy: you give them
$6.99 of value, period.
Oh, I'll even give you an upgrade.
Give them 7.99 of value, and price it at 6.99.
What they were thinking, because they were
the big corporate guys, how do you sell a
5.99 toy for 6.99?
I get that, you can't sell that because people
will understand you're overpricing it.
I'm saying build a Cadillac and sell it at
Ford Motor prices, and you can sell that all
day long, because people understand value
and they can do it.
Because I didn't have any big brands.
I didn't have Superman and Batman or Star
Wars.
I had Spawn, and there was only one way I
was going to be able to compete with those
big names, just give them better quality,
and give them more plastic.
Again, never underestimate plastic.
It's like saying, "Do you want the 15-ounce
bar of chocolate for a dollar or the 10-ounce
bar of chocolate?"
"I'll take the 15."
What are you talking about?
Always take the bigger bar.
For a buck, take more chocolate.
Come on, man.
So I was the guy who was just giving them
more, and more, and more.
Tim Ferriss: How did you learn about making
toys, and figure out the process for making
a quality product?
How did you educate yourself on the bits and
pieces, and steps, and right way to approach
it?
Todd McFarlane: I did it slowly.
No, when I finally hung up my last meeting
with somebody wanting to take the rights of
Spawn to make them toys, and I said, "No."
I knew a couple people, and I phoned somebody
who was sort of entrepreneurial, and I said,
"You know anybody that makes toys?"
And they're going, "Oh, yeah, I got a couple
buddies."
And we got on the phone with them, and that
was it.
And they just went, "Yeah, I've been involved
in making toys," and that was it.
You sculpt the toy out of clay, back then,
you can do it digitally now, but back then
it was out of clay.
You make a mold of it, and you send it over
to your factory, and most toys are manufactured
in China, we found factories in China.
And they cut a steel mold, and they go, "How
many do you want?"
And you're off to the races.
So again, it's more complicated than that,
but at its core, it's not really.
If you've got art, you can make art in any
shape you want.
And so what helped me, Tim, more than anything
else, and I've said this, I've never invented
anything original.
I've never done anything new.
What I've done is taken everything that I've
seen with my eyes and just made it sexier
and cooler, period.
That's it.
That's the recipe.
Everybody who's out there is listening and
wants to be an entrepreneur, stop putting
the pressure on yourself to think you have
to come up with something new and original.
You do not.
You just have to add three percent sexy to
it, and you will now be the genius.
I'll give you an example.
10, 12 years ago, there was a guy named Steve
Jobs, you may have heard of him.
And he went up on stage one day and he said,
"Ladies and gentlemen," I remember the day,
there was a bunch of people, and he goes,
"We are Apple," because they were doing iPods,
and he go, "We are going to come out with
a phone."
And the people in the audience went, "Steve,
little late to the game.
Cell phones have been out for a while."
"No, but get this, ours can dial people."
"Already been done, Steve."
"And we text," done, "And photos," done, "Download
stuff," done, "Email," done, done, done.
There's nothing you're doing, Steve, that
hasn't been done.
And then the moment he said, "Yes, but when
you text, 'Hi, Mom,' on their phone, you are
touching a QWERTY with plastic buttons.
And when you say, 'Hi, Mom,' on mine, you're
not touching plastic, you're touching glass."
Boom, boom.
It did the exact same thing as every other
phone on the marketplace, except you touched
glass.
That was the genius.
He gave them the sexy glass instead of plastic.
Still have to put H-I-M-O-M, Hi, Mom.
It's still the exact same thing, he just figured
out the three percent.
If you can figure out the three percent on
any idea, they'll make you a genius.
So what's the genius they've given me, Tim?
"Oh, my gosh, Todd, we've done sports figures
for decades.
Oh, my gosh, I've won awards.
Oh, my gosh, Todd, your toys are so detailed
and so realistic.
How do you do it?"
You're asking the wrong question.
The question should be, "How did they not
do it?"
I'll tell you how I do it, easy, we use this
high tech, if you don't understand the high
tech, go to Google, it's called a camera.
And if you take a camera and you push the
button, it gives you a photo.
And if you take the photo, and you take your
clay, and you do not stop manipulating the
clay until it looks like the photo, then it
looks exactly like it.
The question isn't how did I make my toys
look realistic?
The question is, how did they not?
Because the camera has been around for a hundred
years, if not more, how did they not use the
tool?
And so I use photo reference, and I'm a genius.
Let me tell you, Tim, another rule of life.
If you want to be smart, act and hang around
dumb people, because why does using photo
reference get me awards?
It shouldn't.
But God bless dumb —
Tim Ferriss: And those are for the athletes,
is that what you're talking about?
The photographs?
Todd McFarlane: Yeah, for the athletes.
That was it.
Look, we were making toys back then, it's
just manipulating clay.
Clay will go into any position and pose and
shape you want it to.
I wasn't doing anything original, I was just
putting the clay in a different shape.
They had clay too, and they've been making
toys for 50 years.
Why they chose not to put it in those shapes,
I don't know, go ask them.
But some of it, Tim, became crystal clear
to me as I broke into the business why they
didn't do it.
Because if they did the detail that I did,
they would then have to paint it.
Ah, and here's the magic, that every time
you put paint on a toy, that's a penny.
"Oh, now we've got to paint that.
Oh, a penny.
Oh, a penny."
And eventually they go, "That's 7, 8, 10,
12 extra cents.
We can't do that.
Why?
Because we're making tens of millions of toys
times 12 cents."
It just becomes a number.
They're in the business to maximize shareholder
profits every 90 days.
Their job isn't to be great artists, it's
to maximize margins and profits.
So they go, "We need to make 10 million.
How do we make the toy?
We've got to manufacture it for 98 cents."
I do the opposite, Tim.
I go make the product as good as you can,
price it afterwards.
And if it's of value, people will pay you
the money.
It's why people will pay 10,000 for one car,
and other people will give you 70,000 for
another car.
They believe there's a value in that price.
And at Toys"R"Us, they're going, "You can't
have a toy at eight or nine bucks.
People won't give you eight or nine bucks
for a toy," back then.
Of course they will, because they're walking
in another aisle giving you $200 for a PlayStation.
If people think that there is value, they
will give the money to you.
Just make value, price it afterwards.
But they don't, and so they were making cheap,
ugly toys.
God bless them.
I was able to come in and make mediocre toys
and I look like a genius.
Tim Ferriss: So two things real quick on that.
The first is, for people who don't have a
lot of exposure to toys, and there's maybe
a blur between toys and sculpture on some
level, but I just came back from Japan where
I went to a showroom where they have, in effect,
toys, they don't have many movable joints
or anything like that, that sell for thousands
of dollars.
They cost as much as a car, and they're video
game characters that have been morphed into
these beautiful three-dimensional, in effect,
plastic sculptures.
There's always a market for high quality.
Todd McFarlane: At a price!
At a price.
High quality at a price.
Tim Ferriss: At a price.
How did you think about distribution?
You didn't want to be right next to the Teletubbies,
so what did you do?
Todd McFarlane: No.
Well, okay, here's where beggars and choosers
come.
Look, I've said to people before, "If you're
going to have any amount of success in your
life, one of the people you have to hang around
with is that guy named dumb luck."
He has to come be a visitor every now and
then.
So I'm going to give you my dumb luck moment.
In comic books, I hate to say it, my dumb
luck moment was that an artist on a book literally
died, and there was an opening.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, I remember that.
Todd McFarlane: Okay, so he's dead.
Todd, not good for him, good for you.
My big break in toys was — and do not do
what I'm just about to say, because I don't
think this lightning is going to strike in
the same place a couple times.
I went to Toy Fair in New York City, comes
once a year, and this is where everybody brings
all their worldly goods.
At that time, this was back in 1994, Hasbro,
let's just take a big toy company, or Mattel,
they had their own building, 10 stories high,
filled with everything.
And the buyers would go into that building,
circle the floor one, go up the floor two,
and go all the way up and down 10 floors.
I, on my first Toy Fair, was in a building
that only had five floors.
I was on one floor, but on that floor there
was 20 rooms.
I was in one room, and that room was cut into
40 pieces.
My space was five feet by five feet.
Okay, now I'm at Toy Fair, and I'm in this
little corner here, and even dumber than that,
Tim, I don't even have a prototype.
This is how stupid I was, I didn't even bring
a prototype, we didn't have time to get it
done.
Tim Ferriss: Wait, so you bring — sorry,
keep going.
I don't want to interrupt, but I'm just like,
"What the Hell are you doing?"
Todd McFarlane: I'll tell you what I brought,
a drawing of Spawn on foamcore, and I cut
it out and I put it in — so I go, "It's
going to look sort of like that drawing."
That was it, that was my sell, that was my
whole speech.
And, oh, by the way, I had made some Hot Wheel
toys based on a funny car that I had bought,
and I'd hand them the Hot Wheel.
Okay, and now the moment.
At this point, Toys"R"Us is number one toy
buyer, not Walmart, and pretty soon Walmart's
going to crush them, probably within six months.
But at that point, Toys"R"Us is the toy buying
gods.
And then, we're in this room with 40 of us,
like a bad swap meet when I was a kid.
And the door opens up, and everybody stands
up and snaps like they're in an army barracks
and the sergeant has come in.
And I'm like, "Huh, what's that about?"
Now, again, the room was so small that you
had to come down a little bit of a walkway,
and then bend, there was a jog, and I was
around the jog.
So I didn't know, I just saw people stand
up and present themselves in front of their
beds.
And it's like, "Oh, okay."
And so I go around the corner to see, and
I go, "Who is that?"
And they're going, "Oh, my God, that's the
buyer from Toys"R"Us.
And it was like The Pope had come into the
room.
And it was like, "Oh, my God."
So I was watching him come, and as he's walking
closer and closer, down towards where I was
standing, if he walked by you, he wasn't buying
anything.
So it was a really cool visual, I still have
this moment, where it's like as you walk by
people, you could just see them collapse physically
because it's like, "Oh, shit, he's not buying
mine."
And he'd keep walking by, and they'd go, "Oh,
crap, oh, crap, oh, crap, oh, crap, oh, crap."
And then I went, "Oh, I guess I better go
stand by my barrack, and my bed."
And so I stood in front of my little thing,
and they come around the corner, and guess
what?
The Toys"R"Us buyer stopped at my place.
Now, Tim, did this buyer care about Spawn?
No.
Did he even know who Spawn was?
Did he know who I was?
Of course he didn't.
So why did he stand there?
This is the moment, he had an assistant, and
the assistant looked like he was about 21
or 22.
And then the magic words, "Hey, boss, this
is the guy I was talking to you about."
Now remember, at this point, Spawn the comic
book is number one in the nation.
So basically, this kid, I don't even remember
his name, I owe my career to this dude.
And when he said, "This is a guy I'm talking
to you about," and all that Toys"R"Us buyer
said, he just looked at it, and just went,
"Let me ask you a question.
Can you get it to me at this price?"
"Yes, sir."
Did I know if I could, Tim?
Of course I didn't.
Always say yes to any opportunity; figure
out whether you can actually do it later.
"Can you give me at that price?"
"Of course I can."
"Can you deliver it on this date?"
"Fine."
I didn't know if I could, either.
I didn't even have factories at that point.
And so he goes, "If you can do that, I'll
put you in all my stores, I'll go storewide."
And just so you guys know, if they take a
sample, they don't usually put you storewide.
But he said, I don't know who his assistant
was, he must have been bending his ear, he
goes, "I'll put you storewide."
And I went, "Yes, sir."
So he left all of a sudden all the other people
in the room came around me, because it was
like, "Oh, my God," like I just won the lotto.
And then, this is why those moments matter,
I couldn't even get a meeting with Walmart,
and Kmart, and Target and those people back
then.
And now, all of a sudden, I'm in Walmart's
room, and I get to now say, "Well, just to
let you know, I've got this Spawn product,
and it will be going storewide in Toys"R"Us."
Now does Walmart know anything about me or
Spawn?
Of course they don't.
But what they don't want to do is get beat
by their competition.
So they go, "Toys"R"Us going storewide?"
"Yeah."
"Okay, we'll take some."
And then, the dominoes.
I go to Kmart, and Target, and all these other
places, and then you just keep adding.
"Well, Toys"R"Us and Walmart are on board,"
and they're like, "What are we missing?"
And it just becomes this thing.
The next thing you know, I'm in all these
big stores, and I go, "Wow, without even having
so much as a prototype."
It doesn't usually work that way.
Now, once you get into the stores, you must
now sell.
Because people go, "Wow, Todd, you got your
product selling at Walmart," or whatever.
Is that —
Tim Ferriss: Hold on, we're skipping a few
steps.
What was the hardest part of figuring out
how the Hell to make that volume of toys?
Because I'm just thinking about the upfront
cost.
Thinking about it from the standpoint of Toys"R"Us,
they're like, "Okay, great, we'll give you
net 90 terms.
We have the ability to return all of them
if they don't sell," it could just kill you
financially, I would think.
So how do you think —
Todd McFarlane: No, they don't return.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
All right, tell me more.
Because if it was a Home Shopping Network
or something, I don't think this is absolutely
accurate, but with some retailers, they have
all these terms that can just crush you if
it's a lot of inventory.
Todd McFarlane: Yeah, I've been fortunate
enough that both toys and comic books are,
if you order, it's yours.
Okay, what you want to do on in the toy side
is to make sure that they're not overbuying.
Both parties need to be realistic.
And it's one of the reasons I think, Tim,
that I've survived as long as I have, because
I've talked them down from orders.
Which is actually the opposite of what they're
used to.
Which I go, "I know you want 75,000 units
of that.
But you know what, why don't we start you
at 40?
I'll build some inventory, it'll be on my
nickel.
And if you need more, then we'll just supply
you as you need.
I think if you buy 75..."
Because here's the math, just so everybody
knows.
You buy 75 ,and you sell 60, they're going
to go, "Ah, I got 15,000 in inventory, it's
not a success."
If you give them 40, and then they have to
buy another 20, and they sell 60, they go,
"Wow, we ordered 50 more than our original
order."
You're still at 60, but one, they're disappointed,
and one, they're not.
You're still playing some weird mind games
a little bit so that they feel good about
whatever number was there.
And again, I'm not a public company, and I
don't have to maximize profits.
My goal is, I've told all my employees, "Get
me to zero every year, and we get to do it
again for another year."
So as long as we're money in, money out, sort
of about the same, let's keep doing it.
I'm okay, I don't need to impress anybody.
My kids, I've already paid for their college,
they're off, the house is paid for, we're
good.
My wife and I are good.
We don't need —
Tim Ferriss: Is the paired directive just
like, "Let's make the best stuff we possibly
can?"
Because there's probably a couple of paired
principles, I would imagine, that go with
that.
Todd McFarlane: That was it.
The company came from one simple question,
"Why can't toys be cooler?"
Again, I was looking at it from an artistic
point of view.
I wasn't asking it from a business point of
view.
Again, you find out what that means when you
ask that question.
And so I go, "Why can't they make cooler toys?"
I found out, Tim, that the reason they weren't
making cooler toys is because, again, like
I said, every time they did an extra joint,
or an extra movement, or an extra paint job
or something, it was pennies, and it just
added up.
And so I ran into this thing where I had my
prototypes at Toy Fair, because I started
actually making prototypes, and each year
I would bring them.
And we would sculpt at twice the size of the
final product.
Why?
Because the bigger you sculpt it, the more
detail you can put in it.
And when you shrink it down, it holds the
detail.
So I would bring these sculpts, and I'd bring
them to the showrooms.
And the buyers would go, "Yeah, Todd, they
look really, really, really nice.
I get it, but what's the product going to
look like?
It's never going to look like this."
And I went, "What are you talking about?
It's going to look exactly like this."
And they're like, "Silly boy, that's not how
it works."
I found out, because I spied on Hasbro and
Mattel and all the big guys, I was able to
get into their showrooms, that they were doing
this thing where they would bring these prototypes
out that were awesome.
Think of them as like the concept cars at
an auto show, but you never will see those
cool cars.
They're just there, they're eye candy.
And I remember seeing this one toy that was
super awesome.
And I went, "Wow, that's good."
And then I saw it months later, literally
at the store, and it was blue plastic.
Didn't put even a drop of paint on it.
So what I ended up having to do, because I
was paying for the sins of these public companies,
is that I then took my prototypes, and I showed
from step 1 to step 10.
And when the buyer got to step 10, guess what
it was?
It was the product, in package, manufactured.
I go, "That's the manufactured toy, that's
what it's going to look like in your store."
And they couldn't believe it, that it was
like, "Whoa, that looks just like your prototype."
"Yes, that's what I've been saying."
Tim Ferriss: What's the point of a prototype?
Todd McFarlane: Right, but everybody else
had been using a prototype just to —
Tim Ferriss: Was doing it the other way.
Todd McFarlane: — yeah, to sucker them in.
So eventually, they got to the point that
like, "Hey, if McFarlane shows you something,
that's actually what it's going to look like."
And they started buying into that maybe there
was a quality component to these products
that were coming in.
I didn't have any big brands, so I had to
beat them with pricing and quality, because
how else am I going to survive next to Star
Wars and Transformers and G.I.
Joe and Marvel?
I can't.
I have to just —
Tim Ferriss: And what year is this, roughly,
would you say?
Todd McFarlane: Well, we started the toy company
in '94, and so literally from the first time,
we hit the ground running.
And here's the thing that's interesting, Tim,
is that if you look at the first two, three,
four waves of toys I put out, they were winning
awards.
And people were going, "Oh, my God, Todd,
look at you.
You've upgraded the whole industry."
And if you look at those toys, compared to
my standards today, they are laughable.
And even yet, back then, just that upgrade
put me on the map.
And here's the other thing too, nobody else
was doing what I was doing in terms of quality,
in terms of the pricing that went with it,
and then in terms of brand selection.
So here's the thing about big corporations.
Their blessing and their curse is their size.
They have more people, more money, more everything,
they can squish you at every moment.
But because of that giant, enormous size,
they don't move fast.
And if you can just be quick and nimble with
your business — I never once said, "I'm
going to slay the giant."
That's never the question, "Todd, how do you
take down Hasbro?"
No, you're asking the question in reverse.
Not how do I take down Hasbro and Mattel,
they're billion-dollar empires.
The question is, how do billion-dollar empires
not squish me?
I am a gnat.
How can they not kill me?
Why would Hasbro and Mattel, or any other
public company, want me to have one foot of
space in Walmart?
That's their territory, that's their money.
And so the question is, why can't they kill
me?
And the answer is, because when you're big,
and you're a giant, and you're a sloth, and
I'm a mosquito, and I'm biting you on your
right arm.
By the time you contemplate slapping that
mosquito, you're so slow with your movement,
that by the time you slap your arm, I'm on
the other side.
They can't move quick enough, Tim.
And that's their weakness.
And the weakness in toys was they will never
do anything outside their comfort zone.
What does that mean?
They'll never make Freddy Krueger, they'll
never make The Terminator toy, they'll never
make The Matrix, they'll never make, essentially,
R-rated toys.
And I felt that there was a need, that you
could sell toys to adults, you just have to
put it in the right content.
I can sell a toy to my mom, I just have to
make it look like Tom Jones, and she'll buy
it, because she loves Tom Jones.
So if you put it in the right brand, then
there's an audience that's out there.
And now we call it geekdom.
And I was the only guy doing it, so everything
I was doing was like, "Oh, my gosh."
There's now dozens of people and companies
that do what I do, so I'm not nearly as unique
anymore.
But back then, I was the trailblazer.
Tim Ferriss: Let's talk about 1994.
The reason I asked about that timing ties
into where you were going a handful of minutes
ago with respect to how do you sell these
toys.
How do you get the sell through once you get
toys placed storewide in, say, a Toys"R"Us?
And 1994 is relevant, because I was thinking,
how would you have any direct fan outreach
to live sales?
Todd McFarlane: Right, the internet, it doesn't
exist.
Tim Ferriss: Because now you have social,
you have email, even email was really nascent
in terms of mainstream adoption in 1994.
So a couple of questions, and you can tackle
them in any order.
One is, how on Earth do you actually ensure
these toys sell once you get them at retail?
The second is related to the comment you made
about so-and-so huge toy company owning real
estate in a given retail store or chain.
And I know that it's fairly common at retail
for people to pay for placement.
They pay extra, they pay the retailer for
end caps, they own the first, say, 20 feet
of a store.
I'm making up this example, but Coca-Cola,
boom, they own the first 20-feet deep at A,
B, and C retailers.
And you literally cannot invade that territory,
it's just not possible, it's been paid for.
This is true in publishing as well, with books
and so on.
There are all these, they might call them
co-marketing fees, they might call them placement
fees.
There are all sorts of crazy incentives that
make it hard for a smaller company to break
in.
So one is, how on Earth do you sell these
toys when you have them placed at retail?
But then, maybe the precursor to that is,
how do you even get the placement?
Maybe this doesn't exist in toys, but do you
have to pay those placement fees?
In which case, how do you pay for it?
Todd McFarlane: There are iterations of what
you're talking about, but not quite what you're
saying.
I think this is closer to what the reality
is.
The stores, let's say they have a run of a
hundred feet.
Again, I'm in the boys toy action figure aisle,
let's call it aisle five.
Aisle five is a hundred feet long.
I think the buyers, for the most part, go,
"I'm going to dedicate 85 percent of that
to the big brands."
And we all know what they are, because we
see foot upon foot upon foot of these brands.
And they rotate them out depending on what
the movies are, and what's hot out in the
zeitgeist.
But they go, "Okay, 85 percent of that's going
to be given to the thing that's going to be
in every company's..."
I don't care whether you're Kmart, Walmart,
Amazon, everybody's going to have it.
Then there's the 15 percent left.
And the 15 percent is "Ah, this is just in
case we're missing something.
Just to give us a little bit of diversity,
just so that we can hedge our bet at the roulette
table a little bit."
And that was the space that I needed to get
into.
I needed to figure out, could I rise and get
into the sales that were worthy of that 15
percent?
And so, to your first question, how did I
get people to know and buy the Spawn toys
at the beginning, I didn't.
In all honesty, the internet, and I know this
seems foreign to people, was literally just
in its infancy.
And so that wasn't the gameplay.
The only play was value, quality, and put
it together, and hopefully people would notice
it.
Because the upside of making toys and action
figures is the packaging is see through, so
you actually get to see what you're buying.
There's no fake photo, and then you take it
home and you go, "Man, that didn't look that
good."
What you see is what you get.
And I think that my toys just quickly passed
the eye test to a lot of people.
And again, remember, I was coming off setting
records with Spider-Man, and then we quickly
went to do the comic books with Spawn, so
there was a big fan base that was there.
And they went, "Oh, my gosh, Todd's going
to do some toys."
So they jumped on very quickly, and as you
know, in any business, you're only as good
as your last set of sales.
It doesn't matter what you have today, they
just look at the data of your last ones.
And so once the first series came out and
did really well, and then the second one continued,
because I got to put some characters in it,
I don't know, it just — and then the internet
started to become a little bit relevant.
And we were getting traffic even on our own
website that was phenomenal.
I was getting pulled into Hollywood, people
going, "Todd, how are you getting that much
traffic?"
I mean big studio asking me how I was getting
the traffic that they weren't getting as a
studio.
So at some point, the geeks just find you,
Tim.
And I would like to say that I knew what I
was doing all this time, and that somehow
I'm a savant.
It's not true.
You just try your darnedest, and sometimes
that 30-foot shot banks into the bucket, and
you score the three points and you go, "Wow."
I can't say I can replicate it.
But what you do is, once you have momentum,
can you keep momentum?
It's like a good disc jockey, the good disc
jockey keeps people on the floor dancing.
The bad ones figure out how to put on a song
that everybody walks off.
I need to basically keep the momentum going
and finding places.
Here's where I kept the momentum.
We started selling places like Virgin Records
and Tower records and KB Toys and Hot Topic
and we were going to what I was said earlier,
non-traditional places, and they were buying
lots and lots of toys.
You know why?
Because I was making like crazy R-rated, at
times gory, toys, and then all they cared
about was the one magic sentence, "Walmart's
not buying this."
Boom, "We'll take it."
Because now they don't have to compete, because
if you go into competition with the big boys,
everybody has the same product, you're just
going to get into a pricing war.
And they want a product that the big boys
didn't have.
And back then I could make anything up in
my head, put it in the plastic, and I had
hundreds and hundreds of thousands of sales
waiting for these guys who didn't want to
compete with the big boys.
Unfortunately, the world changes and Babbage's
and Virgin Records and KB, all these companies
don't even exist anymore.
So there was a consolidation and some of the
fun that we were having at the beginning is
no longer sort of available to us.
Tim Ferriss: So momentum, you strike me as
someone who's a very good sort of creative
and business DJ, to push the metaphor, which
I like, you mentioned the four pillars, games,
TV, movies, toys.
It seems like toys came in one of the earlier
chapters in terms of setting that pillar of
the foundation.
Where did, whether it's music, TV, directing,
any of those other elements, come into the
picture?
Todd McFarlane: Okay, so I'm going to get
to that.
Let me just go back to toys and tell one more
quick story —
Tim Ferriss: Sure.
Todd McFarlane: — on the toy end.
So there is another story that people to this
day scratched their head on, and it was in
1998, Mark McGwire — if you're a baseball
fan — Mark McGwire and Sammy Sosa were going
for the home run title.
And at the end of the season Mark McGwire
had hit 70 home runs, the prior record was
61 home runs by Roger Maris.
Sammy Sosa hit 66 that year.
Okay, why is that relevant?
Because for a couple years I had been — I'd
started my toy company in 1994 and I'm an
athlete, and again, stick to what you know.
I know sports.
And I was trying to make sports toys and I
couldn't make sports toys.
Why?
I couldn't even get a meeting because I'm
a nobody.
The NHL, major league baseball, the NBA, NHL,
why would anybody let me in the front door?
They wouldn't.
And so you have to figure out back doors and
alternatives.
So here is the play.
And again, from one perspective it seems like
the dumbest thing that a human being can do.
I'll give you what I was doing during that
play.
Anyways, the 70 McGwire ball, the last ball
he hit that was a record, goes up for an auction
in Madison Square Garden.
I'm the anonymous bidder.
Anyways, nobody's ever spent more than $300,000,
$400,000 on any baseball paraphernalia.
At the end of the auction, I end up winning
the 70 ball and it costs me three million
dollars.
10 times what the previous record was, three
million dollars.
Now you can say, and I understand this perspective,
why would any human being with a brain spend
three million for a $3 baseball?
Why would they do that?
Especially, given a couple years later, Barry
Bonds broke the record.
Oh, by the way, I had to go buy that ball
too.
But I bought the 70 ball.
Here's what the 70 ball did and it seems like
the stupidest thing.
Three million dollars for a baseball.
It's stupid.
You're never going to get your money back
out of it.
It depends on how you're looking at it.
Here's how I was looking at it.
I knew that spending and getting that ball
would get me headlines.
So instantly it was a national story and I
was on lots of talk radio shows and TV shows
and everything.
I mean I canvased the planet.
And do you know how much money it would cost
to get that attention by buying ads in any
of those areas?
It would cost you way more than three million,
but let's put that to the side.
Here's what it did.
Those headlines then got seen by all the sports
leagues and the unions.
And when I phoned the next time and said,
"Hey, I'm Todd McFarlane and maybe you've
heard of me, I bought the McGwire ball, but
I'd just like to talk to you.
I'm also in the toy business."
They let me in the door and I got to have
a conversation with them.
In short order I ended up having the license
for baseball, football, basketball, and hockey.
I did it for 13 years.
I can tell you, ladies and gentlemen, I made
more than three million dollars in profits
on those toys multiple times over those 13
years.
So at some point you have to put up an ante
on the table to play the big game with the
big boys in poker.
And my ante, unfortunately, was a three million
dollar baseball so that they took that as
saying, which, just so everybody knows, it
was every red cent I had and then some.
I had to beg, borrow and steal to pay for
it.
Then what ended up happening, people see those
headlines and they go, "Oh, if he's got three
million dollars to wipe his ass on a baseball,
he must be successful, he must have a lot
of money.
Bring the successful guy into the room."
And I got the four licenses and it was there.
One last comment on it, why do you care that
I spent three million on a baseball?
Because for me, I've made it over multiple
times, and any time I do any interview, because
I'm now the expert — just so everybody knows
— guess how many interviews I did when Aaron
Judge, this year, was going to do a ball,
people were asking me how much the ball is
worth.
I'm now an expert because I spent an ungodly
amount on one ball, I've become an expert.
This is how silly all this is.
But I get to amortize that three million dollars
once again that's sitting there.
But if I don't spend that money and I don't
get there, I don't get to the table, then
my company never does any of it.
And here's why, this is one of the reasons,
Tim, I can't be public, because you can't
play that game.
I can't go to the shareholders and to the
board and the chairman of the board and say,
"Hey, I've got this gut feeling that if I
do this one thing I think it will pay off."
If you can't categorize it on a spreadsheet
in rows and columns and tell them what it's
going to equate to in terms of capital money
and profit margins in 90 days, you're going
to get shot down.
And this is why I can't go public.
And let me tell you, when my toy companies
were flying, did Wall Street come and knock
on my door?
Of course they did, Tim.
Of course they did.
But I horrified them to the point that I'd
become a bit of a talking moment because I've
run into them years later.
They would come, and here's what I found with
Wall Street.
"Todd, we're going to give you X amount of
dollars and we're going to buy your company."
"Okay, that's cool, but I'm still in control."
"Well, no, no, no, no, at that amount of money
you're not in control."
"What?
I've got to give up control of my company?"
"Uh-huh."
"For what, your money?"
"I already got got money.
I don't need any of your money."
So they're like, "Okay."
And then here's where Wall Street is literally
a one-trick pony.
"Okay Todd, we won't give you X amount of
money.
We see that you're a little stubborn, we'll
give you 2X."
"Okay, but if you give me twice the money,
do I have control?"
"No."
"Whoa, that's a problem."
"Todd, last time, we'll give you 3X of money."
"Guys, let me now define what money is to
me.
Here's the word — I'm Canadian so maybe
you guys in America do it a little bit differently.
So my dad taught me a word, it's called useless.
And here's what useless is.
It's when you have something and you don't
use it.
So do you know that I have money in the bank
right now, which basically means I'm not using
it.
So it's kind of useless to me because I'm
not using it because it's just sitting in
a bank doing nothing."
Do you know the reaction to people from Wall
Street when you call their one product useless?
Do you know how horrifying it is?
That they're just going, "What did you just
call money?"
And eventually they stopped coming.
And then I remember I was at a party years
later and I introduced myself and then they
went, "Todd McFarlane, why do I know that
name?"
And it was somebody I'd never met before.
"Oh, you're the guy that doesn't like money."
And let me tell you, and I've told everybody,
look guys, I'm not a saint.
I'm not a saint.
I can be bought.
We all have our price.
The price though that I needed that day was
that they would give me enough money that
I would then give up control of the company
but have so much money I could then buy it
back at a discount, fire all of them, and
I'd still have a profit and I'd have my company
back.
But nobody's ever given me that deal so I've
just never sold the company and they've stopped
saying, "Todd."
I'm just a madman.
So anyways, over to Hollywood now.
Tim Ferriss: Well, before we get to Hollywood,
I want to do a deep dive on the madman part.
So you mentioned that this three million was
basically all the money you had and then some.
You strike me as a risk taker, but you strike
me as a calculated risk taker.
You don't give me the impression of being
reckless.
Some people could say, well, if you say yes
to Toys"R"Us and you haven't even figured
out manufacturing, that's reckless.
But it's not reckless because what's the downside?
You can't figure it out and you're like, "Sorry
pal, I can't make it work."
The downside's actually really, really limited
for you.
Three million bucks, different story.
So given that the NHL and NBA and so on hadn't
returned your phone calls up to that point,
what gave you the confidence or how did you
do the calculus?
Did you have enough safety net that you were
like, "Ah, this could suck for a year or two
if they don't actually open up to me?"
How did you think about this?
What was the reasoning going into it?
Todd McFarlane: Okay, so there's two things
that I thought were, again, keeping the momentum
going in my favor.
One, I had the data of all the toys that I
was doing with Spawn.
And Spawn at that point, it hit a point where
consecutive series that were coming out, I
think we got all the way up to 36, was the
second longest running streak of series of
toys other than I think Transformers.
It was even longer than Star Wars.
Star Wars had gone quiet and gone dark for
a while.
So again, there was a little bit of that.
But I planted one small seed before I made
the crazy play, and the small seed was I was
able to get to the players' union of the NHL.
Because of the four major sports most people
will say, especially in terms of revenue,
that the NHL is the fourth one, the stepchild,
if you will.
And so I didn't go to the league because I
knew I couldn't get there.
I went to the union.
And just so you know, if you ever make any
sports toys of any current players, you must
have two licenses.
You have to license the union so you can get
the players and their likeness, and then you
have to get a contract from the league so
that you can get basically their uniforms
and their logos.
And then you have to glue the two together
and you have a double royalty that you have
to pay.
So it's not the best model, but if you want
do it that's how it works.
So I went to the NHL players' union, which
was like nobody ever gives us any money because
they just sell jerseys and stuff with logos,
everything's logo, logo, logos on the hat.
And I said, "I'm going to make toys of your
players but unfortunately I can't put their
uniforms on them because I don't have an NHL.
I'm going to have to do generic uniforms."
And they went, "Yeah, sure, we'll take money."
So I had in my back pocket one small seed.
I had the union of the NHL.
So that later, once I spent the money on the
McGwire ball and I was hoping I would get
a meeting, then I could go in there and say
— one of the first meetings I took was with
the NHL per se, and I just pulled out my toys
and I go, "Guys, look at these toys.
Aren't they cool?
They look just like Pavel Bure and Mario Lemieux
and Wayne Gretsky.
Look at them, these are super awesome, right?
Here's the thing, notice that I don't get
to use your uniform."
And at that point I sort of had a conversation
with them and they were threatening to sue
me because they said that my generic uniforms
were looking like them.
I think I had even done some generic McGwires
too.
And I'd even at that point then went to the
NFL union and I go, "Hey, I've got the baseball
and I've now got the hockey."
Again, it all tumbles.
And so I was then able to go into rooms and
I remember these odd conversations you have,
Tim, that I just want to hit my head against
walls, but whatever.
I'm in a room with the NHL and there's like
six lawyers, there's always lawyers, and they're
threatening to sue me because I'm doing like
a sort of a generic uniform on one of the
players that I had there.
And they're going, "We're going to sue you.
You cannot do these toys."
And I'm like, "Oh, yeah?
You sue my ass.
You sue my ass, because here's how it works
and you guys aren't even smart enough to know
how this works.
Number one, you're sitting here right now
across this table telling me you own everything.
Good, sue me, and if you win, you don't get
a fucking ounce of upgrade.
You say you got a hundred percent at the end,
the best you can hope for is a hundred percent.
"Go ahead and do it.
But if you pay attention and you do a little
bit of research on me, you're pulling the
wrong tiger's tail, because I'll do this.
Because here's the thing, if we go to court
and you find out that you don't have a hundred
percent, and I'm betting you don't, that not
only do I get a piece of that a hundred percent,
it is going to basically be a story for every
human being on this planet that they can now
go against you.
So you've got two choices.
You can either go to court and say that somehow
you own reddish colors and bluish colors,
if you want to make that argument be my guest,
or what I'm saying, I've got a check for half
a million dollars here I'd like to shove down
your throat to give me your fucking logos.
I don't know, sue me and potentially lose
a hundred percent or take a half a million
dollars.
This seems like my six-year-old could figure
out what this thing is."
Eventually they took the half a million bucks.
So what are you talking about, of course they
did.
Of course they did.
Stop it.
And sadly I had to sort of play the same conversation
with everybody.
When I had the NFL and I'm like, "I'm doing
your players.
The question is, do you want any of the cash?"
I mean at some point forget the art and forget
anything else, just get down to the core of
it.
"Do you want any of this money I'm about to
make?
The answer is yes or no.
And if you don't, fine.
Oh, by the way, I thought you were in the
commerce business because you're a public
company, but you guys go ahead and do what
you want to do."
It is amazing how many times I've had to try
and shove money down people's throats.
But anyways, that's corporate America.
They do their thing, I do mine.
Tim Ferriss: So doing your thing, let's hop
across some lily pads and touch on, whichever
you want touch on next, the music, TV, movies,
how do any of these other elements, I know
you've mentioned games, but which of these
elements enter the picture?
Todd McFarlane: So let's talk about TV first.
So again, go back to the release of the Spawn
comic book after we leave Marvel, the group
of us leave Marvel, my character Spawn comes
out, bam, shoots to the top of the charts.
And for months and months, even maybe a couple
of years it was the number one selling book.
So it was at the top of the chart.
So like I said, phone calls were constantly
coming.
I get the phone call and on the other line
is HBO, legit at that point.
I mean, what are you talking about, they're
still legit, right?
But they were one of the big sort of companies
out there.
And I go, "Oh, cool."
And they said, "Hey, we want to do some animation."
And I knew animation is like Saturday morning
cartoons and a couple of my partners at Image
Comics had sold and were going to get Saturday
morning cartoons, which they did.
But I did Spawn, again, the guy from the pit
of Hell, it just not wasn't what I wanted.
And I don't say this as a joke, and I'll tell
you why I asked this one question.
I go, "Hey, guys, it's cool.
I appreciate your enthusiasm.
Let me ask you just one question.
I just have one question for you.
Can I say 'Fuck' in my show?"
And it wasn't meant to be a joke.
And they paused and then they said, "Yeah,
probably, why not?"
And that was all I needed to hear.
Not that I wanted to use that word, Tim, not
that I wanted to do and show naked women or
anything.
I just thought that if they were willing to
basically say yes to that, then I had a wide
lane of creativity.
And the reason I needed a wide lane, because
my character lives in a dark, serious world
and I'm going to have corrupt policemen and
I'm going to have mafia people and I'm going
to have criminals, I'm going to have drug
addicts.
And these people don't talk politely when
they get mad.
You have to be able to go into watching an
R-rated movie.
You have to be able to have a certain dialect
for your characters that matches who they
are.
And so I just needed to, if the moment came,
I needed to be able to do that and have the
creative freedom to do it.
So when they said, "Yeah, sure," then I was
like, "Cool, then let's do it.
Oh, one more thing.
I know nothing about animation, never spent
a second on it, but I've got to be in charge,
so you guys go and have that talk and do what
you've got to do."
And they came back and said, "Yeah, yeah,
yeah, you can be in charge but we're going
to put some good people on your flanks," which
they did, and we went in there.
And so I was working on HBO animation.
At this time, Tim, HBO had started an animation
division.
I think there was five, maybe six shows going
on, of which Spawn was one.
Very quickly, the other five failed and I
was sort of the lone wolf by the end of it.
But when we first came out, I was in the room
now with this group of people they had amassed
to make an animated show, who collectively
probably had 600 years of experience, which
is cool.
But there's also moments where I realized
I'm in front of people at times who have been
institutionalized.
And here's the frustrating thing that I've
run into over and over and over in my life.
The bark being way better than the bite.
And so artists would go, all these creative
people, all these people who worked on animation,
"Man, if we could only do it our way, man,
these people, these executives, they don't
know anything."
I've heard that over and over and over.
And we finally get to a point where literally
we can almost do anything, and guess what
a lot of them did?
They just went back to status quo.
And so being the dumbest guy in the room,
I used to ask these questions.
Any question, there's a legitimate answer
why you can't do it.
It's usually time or money.
"Oh, you can do it but it's going to cost
more money."
"Can't do that, I have a budget."
"No, it doesn't cost any more money, but it's
going to take twice as long."
"We don't have the luxury of the deadline."
So that's it.
And I understand.
So I would constantly be asking these questions,
"Can we do this?"
"No."
"Why?"
"Because of this."
But every now and then, being the dumb guy
in the room I didn't know where the guardrails
were so I'd ask a question and then you get
the moment, Tim, which is you ask a question
and you've got 50 people in a room, and I
go, "If we do this will it cost us any more
time or money?
I mean a little bit of effort maybe, but about
the same."
And then you get, to me, the golden moment,
a pregnant pause, silence.
So there was nobody in the room with 600 years
experience saying, "No, we can't do that.
No, we can't do that."
And I went, "So you're saying that it won't
take more time?"
"No."
"And it won't cost more money?"
"So why don't we do it?"
"Well, that's not how we do it here."
"No, no, I understand that's not how we do
it.
I'm not asking that question.
I'm saying will it take more time or money
and you're saying no."
Why are we figuring out how to self edit ourself,
self censor ourself, when nobody else is?
This is a crime.
Why are we putting guardrails on ourselves?
We should be smashing up against the walls
until the executives upstairs go, "Whoa guys,
whoa, whoa, whoa, pull it back."
Right?
That's what we should be doing.
But when you've had a dog that has been in
a small backyard for so long that it gets
comfortable, that the moment you throw the
doors open to the wild farmlands and you go,
"Run, Rover, go."
It was amazing how many creative people sat
down instead of running because that's all
they knew.
They knew one way to do animation and they
knew one way to draw it and they knew one
way to storytell.
And they only knew one way and one way and
one way and one way.
And here's the frustration, by the end of
the three years we were butting heads because
they all thought I was the crazy guy and whatever
else.
We won Emmys on that show, and I remember
being up on the stage and getting my Emmy
and behind me was 15 of these people, most
of them I was constantly having to basically
drag them into some of these decisions.
And they were all holding an Emmy in their
hands too and with a big smile.
And I was like going, "Oh, my God, here you
are, so happy you've got an Emmy in your hand,
and you were resistant to almost everything;
that is the reason why we're up on this stage
today."
It bugged me that I was putting that award
in their hands because they were not willing
participants for the ride.
But the reason we ended up getting canceled
wasn't because people weren't watching it.
It was because, and this is again just the
way of the world, name's Todd, it only rhymes
with God, I don't get to control any of this.
And it was that they had five shows, remember
I said they started an animation show, and
every time a show got canceled, one of the
animations got canceled, they just put all
the costs on the existing show.
And eventually all of them failed except for
me.
And I remember them calling me in saying,
"Todd, we've got to stop the animation."
I go, "Why?"
And they go, "It's getting too expensive."
And I went, "Expensive?
You haven't given me one red cent more than
you did the first year.
I'm working on the exact same budget."
And then I found out I was covering all the
other overhead that had basically failed.
Tim Ferriss: Accrued, yeah.
Todd McFarlane: And so they put that on my
budget and then they have to get so many eyeballs
per dollar and somehow they had put all that
money that had accrued onto mine and it fell
under their threshold and whatever matrix
they used, and they'd never go public with
any of it but it was like that was it.
We were doing the exact same job, winning
Emmys, doing exactly what we were doing, but
now all of a sudden they had to let us go
because somehow the math didn't work for them.
Tim Ferriss: So a question for you about that.
It seems like, and I know this is simplifying,
but you've had this incredible bull run with
Spider-Man, Image Toys and then you have this
television experience, which is super challenging,
it doesn't end the way you probably would've
liked it to end.
Todd McFarlane: Well, we won Emmys, so I'll
take that —
Tim Ferriss: Okay, no, no.
Well, that leads into my question, which is
are you glad you had that experience or would
you have removed it and replaced it with something
else?
Todd McFarlane: No.
Tim Ferriss: How did you contend with that
yourself?
Did you feel good about it at the end?
Todd McFarlane: Yeah, sure.
Tim Ferriss: Proud of it?
Todd McFarlane: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
Todd McFarlane: Tim, this is easy.
There's only one human being I have dominion
over: me.
Period.
My wife, I love her, I've been with her for
over 40 years.
I don't even control her and she's the closest
person that I have in the world.
Okay, I don't worry — I mean, it can be
exhausting at times trying to drag people
to the water but you can't make the horse
drink at times.
So at some point I just go, "Guys, you do
your thing.
I do my thing and we'll just figure it out."
I do not stand by water coolers and complain
about bosses.
I quit jobs and start my own companies.
As a creative person, if I'm going to complain
about how the business works, then I will
then go and become my own businessman.
I consider myself, Tim, to be bilingual.
I have learned the language of business.
I am first and foremost a fluent speaker in
art, that is my native tongue.
But I have learned business to the point where
I can now go into a meeting with executives
or bankers or government people or whatever
and sound like a CEO who happens to be a pretty
good artist.
I can convince them that I'm that guy, that
they go, "Oh, okay, the art is sort of like
he just does it on the side."
Because I've got two choices.
I either let people with experience do the
business side of it and have full trust in
them and knowledge of what they're doing so
I know that I can trust them or I just figure
it out myself.
My personality didn't allow me to put it in
the hands of others.
If I'm going to fail, I want to fail on my
own merits.
And so I just learned business.
Did it take away from the art?
Of course it did.
Every time I'm in one of these dumb meetings
for an hour, I am acutely aware that I am
not creating and everything in my world business-wise
is a byproduct of me doing some kind of creating.
It's a fallout of my me creating.
And when I'm not creating, I don't think I'm
bringing the most value to my company.
I need to be an artist as much as possible.
But I also need to be able to sing and tell
the story of what we do for the company so
that we can get past the nos, because I can
be very stubborn of going, "Well, before you
say no, let me just download you with the
reality of what you're walking away from."
And at the beginning it was all BS, let me
just tell you, it was BS.
But as the years have gone by, there's hardcore
data now.
Tim, let me just again go back a little bit.
Last year, I don't even pay attention to it,
but last year — there's the equivalent of
the Nielsen ratings in toys and they literally
count when something gets scanned at the big
superstores and it goes into a database.
So we're not talking about "You're the most
popular, you've got the coolest toy, Todd,"
those are different awards.
This is data based on sales.
Last year, our line of DC Multiverse toys,
I don't even have the master license of DC
Multiverse, I have a fraction of it.
I have a collective little sliver of it.
And our sliver of that outsold not only the
master toy license of that, but it outsold
everything Marvel and everything Star Wars.
It was the number one selling line in America
and Canada.
My company literally that is a handful of
people sold more toys in action figure lines
than Hasbro, Mattel, Playmates, Spin Master,
all these public companies.
And the question is either I and my people
are geniuses or they're not getting full value
for whatever infrastructure they did.
I think the answer lies somewhere in between.
How is it that I can take on Fortune 500 companies?
Last year I had the number one selling comic
book, the number one selling comic book.
Marvel is owned by Disney.
DC Comics is owned by Warner Bros., AT&T Warner
Bros., Discovery, whatever it is this week.
Those are billion dollar empires.
And my comic book division is four people.
How do four people take on billion dollar
empires and beat them at times at their own
game?
I don't know.
It's a curiosity.
Why aren't they selling more?
I don't know.
Go ask them.
I'm just doing my gig.
But it's doable.
And I'm hoping that the story of a guy like
me should be, hopefully to some people, somewhat
inspirational.
Because every time I read a story where David
took on Goliath and didn't get killed, didn't
slay the giant, just didn't get killed himself,
those should be encouraging of the yes, you
too can go against these guys and succeed.
And here's the thing, as long as your company
is the right size, with the right overhead,
you can make a profit.
So you can make $10,000 a month and make a
profit as long as your overhead is less than
10,000.
Or you can make a hundred million a year and
lose money because your overhead is over a
hundred million.
You just have to right size your company and
you can make money.
Don't worry about being rich.
Just go.
I make 30,000; as long as we spend 25, we're
making five grand a month.
It's a living.
Cool.
And you're having fun doing it.
Tim Ferriss: Two questions related to all
of this, the first is, and we're going to
bounce around chronologically, but how do
you protect or create the time for creativity
and making?
So if we think about it as making versus managing,
so the making is the creative stuff, the managing
is all the meetings, all of the CEO stuff.
I would have to imagine there have been times
where you've looked at your calendar after
a hard week and you're like, "For fuck's sake,
I've spent 90 plus maybe a hundred percent
of my time this week managing stuff."
How have you been able to block out or protect
the time to create?
Have you thought about that as someone who
has all these different business ventures
now?
Todd McFarlane: I think it's the eternal question
we all struggle with.
How do we balance our life?
We all ask that, both on the personal and
the work.
We're always going how does this work?
I, through failures, Tim, found that I was
a five-ball juggler.
And here's what that means, that I don't care
who you are.
I don't care if you're the best juggler in
Vegas and you're with Cirque du Soleil and
you can juggle 25 balls.
Even that person, if you go one ball more
than they're capable of, guess what happens?
All the balls fall.
Every ball you're juggling hits the floor
and it's a mess.
And so I, unfortunately, let the balls drop
at times that I was acutely aware that I was
doing a disservice to certain areas.
I learned that I was a five-ball juggler,
and here's what that means for me.
It means that I'm always constantly juggling
five balls.
But if another opportunity comes along and
I get excited about it and it makes sense
both from an artistic and from a business
CEO level, I must put one of the five balls
I am currently juggling down or put it in
the hands of others and give them full trust
to do what they need to do before I pick up
that new opportunity so that I'm constantly
at five and don't extend myself.
And so it was a lesson hard learned over the
years.
What that also meant was, "Todd, you can't
do all the artwork yourself, so you're going
to have to become a good scout and you're
going to have to find talent."
At some point on a good day, I feel that I
am Phil Jackson when he was coaching the Chicago
Bulls.
I think, maybe not, his conversation went
something like this, "Michael Jordan, Scottie
Pippen, and I don't even know what the name
is of the rest of you dudes, could you guys
just go over there and your job is, could
you put that ball in that bucket?
Oh, by the way, if you have any questions
to that in-depth analysis I just gave you,
I'll be over here in my three-piece suit with
my clipboard and you just come over and ask
me a question."
Phil Jackson was smart enough to find the
proper talent and put it in the proper place
so that the end of that run, not only did
Michael Jordan have six championship rings,
so did Phil.
Do you know how many buckets Phil made during
that time?
Zero.
He was just smart enough to know to put Michael
and the crew out there in the right iterations.
And so there are times where you have to just
go, "Todd, you can't build this all yourself."
There are some things that make sense for
me being the lead and/or even isolating myself
artistically.
There are plenty of other things we do, making
toys, making comic book, making movies, making
video games, all of it, that's a collective
team.
I actually sort of enjoy being with the collective
team because if I can find my Michael Jordans
or my Scottie Pippens and I'm in a meeting
and they show me their skill, artistically
or with ideas or how to promote or how to
sell or market, whatever, in any field in
any sort of skill set, and I feel like I'm
the dumbest guy in the room, those are great
days for me, Tim, because I sit there and
go, "Oh, my gosh, I wouldn't have even thought
of that.
I can't even do it to that skill set.
Thank God they work for me."
I just sit there and go, "Hmm."
If I really want to make it look like that
I'm sort of more important that I am, I'll
say something like, "Interesting, I'll take
it under advisement and get back to everybody
tomorrow," where inside I'm going, "Holy shit,
this is awesome.
I just hope they don't quit and start their
own company and compete against me because
they're super awesome."
And so that's it.
You just have to find talent and coach them
along the way.
I'm just a coach.
I feel like I'm a coach now.
Tim Ferriss: Harkening back to what you said
about last year and toy sales, the example
you gave was DC, so we're not talking about
Freddy Krueger, we're talking about DC.
It's not the R-rated advantage.
Presumably, these are at large retailers.
Todd McFarlane: Oh, yeah.
Tim Ferriss: You no longer have the Hot Topic
advantage.
How are you competing so effectively?
I would imagine also the people who have emulated
and tried to copy the style by adding more
detail and trying to compete.
I assume that.
Maybe that's an incorrect assumption, but
how are you guys still competing so effectively
in selling, certainly as multiple of your
head counts, so much more than these other
guys?
Todd McFarlane: Okay.
Well, let me just tell you, brand matters,
right?
Tim Ferriss: Mm-hmm.
Todd McFarlane: I'd been making toys for 25
years that I said every day of my life, "I
can sell Star Wars, just give me the contract.
What are you talking about?
It's Star Wars, right?
Star Wars."
How come I don't sell a lot of Spider-Man?
Because I don't have the contract.
Eventually, I'd walk around Toy Fair and it
seemed like everybody had a piece of Marvel.
Everybody had a piece of Star Wars and DC
Comics, except for me.
I don't know why I was the only guy.
But somehow, we ended up doing a deal, Warner
Bros. walking away from Mattel.
They had given Mattel both the Master Toy
license and the Collective sliver.
I guess it didn't —
Tim Ferriss: What is the difference between
the Master Toy and the Collective?
I guess I'm not sure what the difference is
between those two.
Would you mind just explaining that?
Todd McFarlane: Well, those definitions are
internal definitions for every corporation.
They define them differently.
But essentially, a Master Toy license means
that you basically, not only get to do action
figures, but you get to do the Nerf gun versions
of them and you get to do the Hot Wheels with
the logos on it.
Tim Ferriss: Right.
Todd McFarlane: Basically, you can do puzzles,
you're in the entire store, if you want to
be.
You've got all the aisles.
I'm in aisle five, boys action figure.
I always said, "No, I don't want to diversify.
I want to just be the king of aisle five,"
if I could.
That's it.
Just focus.
Don't get lost in all the other aisles.
Just be good at one aisle.
I'd rather be a master of one than the jack
of all trades.
Eventually, we ended up, a couple years back,
getting, after decades at trying, finally,
we got the license for the DC Multiverse.
Let me tell you really what the big piece
of that was.
I had the word "Batman" and "Superman" on
my toys.
What are you talking about?
Those are global brands.
I've always told people, "Look," and you and
I have discussed it here, "If you do a quality
product at a fair price and do little bit
of marketing and build a better mouse trap,
you can survive."
How do I know?
I've done it for 25, 27 years prior.
But I always had a but to it.
But if you ever give me a triple A brand on
top of that, on top of that mythology, shit,
get out of the way.
What do you talk about?
Because now I'm going to give them price and
quality and a name that everybody knows.
I've been saying that for years, and guess
what?
They finally give me one of the big brands,
and guess what?
We outsold all of them.
Boom.
Now, here's one of the things, also, that
mattered.
Big companies, and this is their job, I'm
not saying it's good, bad, I'm just saying
this is their job, is to maximize value for
the shareholders every 90 days.
How do you do that?
You just make as much money as you can.
How do you make as much money as you can?
You figure out how to cut corners.
And so one of the ways you cut corners in
our trade of toys is that you reuse the same
pieces.
Lego does the same thing.
I mean, I don't care how ambitious whatever
it is you're buying, there are still certain
blocks.
I mean the colors may be different, but there
are still certain blocks that are universal
in every one of their builds.
And then, they put the unique pieces that
will make it into the shape they need.
But there's still a portion of the reuse of
blocks that have been used for decades because
that's their formula.
Cool.
Works for them.
Toys are sort of the same, that they go, "Oh,
we'll do a generic body and we won't make
anything unique about it.
And then, that way, we can paint it with a
bat symbol on it or a S or a flash and it
all sort works, and we don't have to cut any
more molds.
We don't have to cut any more steel."
Why?
Because that's money.
"And we don't have to do all those things."
Early on, when I was giving Warner Bros. our
lineups and we were talking to them, I go,
"I want to make this character," and they
were talking about this and then they go,
"Oh, we can't really make that character."
I go, "Why?"
And they go, "Well, it doesn't really share
the same look as any other character."
I went, "No, no, I know that.
We're good.
We'll cut some new molds."
When they found out that I was willing to
make new molds, specifically for one character,
they were blown away by that because they'd
been dealing with the big boys.
They were going, "Hold a sec.
You're going to do five new characters and
make five new sets of molds?"
"Uh-huh."
"And that's okay with you?"
"Yeah, it's how I've been doing it for years."
Wow.
Here's why that mattered, Tim, because it
allowed me now, for the very first time, to
make characters that nobody had made prior
to that.
People have been making Superman and Batman
and Wonder Woman toys for decades.
Of course they had.
But some of the other iterations of those
characters and/or B characters or C characters
that look super cool, I don't care if you
even know their name, in plastic, they look
super cool on a shelf.
I was able to make them.
And then I think there was a big enough audience
in geekdom that came by and went, "Oh, my
goodness, nobody's ever made that character
or that character or that character or that
character," and they were able to get, literally,
the rookie cards using sort of trading card.
They were getting the rookie cards of all
these characters that nobody had ever made
before, and I think it mattered.
I think it mattered that I was doing something
different than what the big boys did.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, that makes sense.
All right.
I'm glad I asked.
Thank you for answering.
Where to from there?
Or I should say, not really from there because
these are all parallel lines in a sense.
Todd McFarlane: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: The comic books are going.
The toys are going.
Todd McFarlane: They each create an opportunity.
Again, let's talk about music videos.
You mentioned that.
How do you get to music videos?
I don't even read music.
I can't read a lick of music and I've got
a Grammy.
How's that possible.
Some dumbass kid who doesn't know anything
about music's got a Grammy.
It bothers my wife.
She's a very good pianist and it bugs her
that I've got one, so don't say it out loud
if you come to dinner.
Here's how you get there.
You just find the back door.
They're always going to block the front door.
Status quo is going to always get put in front
of you.
You find the back door.
Here's the back door.
Out of the blue, we're doing the HBO animation.
It's doing pretty well and, again, I'm winning
a couple Emmys.
And then, out of the blue, I don't know why,
go ask him, out of the blue, I get a phone
call from Eddie Vedder.
Eddie Vedder's the lead singer of Pearl Jam.
Eddie then says, "Hey, Todd.
Eddie."
"Hey, Eddie, how you doing, bud?"
"Here's what we want to do, Todd.
The record label is bugging us to do a music
video.
We hate music videos and we don't want to
be in it."
Which is sort of a cool thing that it's like,
"Pardon?
You don't want to be in your own music video?"
"No, and we've been putting them off and putting
them off, but they keep bugging us.
Now we're at the point where I've figured
it out, Todd.
I've been watching this Spawn animation on
TV.
We can do it animated.
Let's just do it animated, and then we don't
have to be in it."
I was like, "Okay, cool."
And so he goes, "Do you want to help us with
it?"
I'm like, 'Yeah, sure, cool.
What's the gig?"
And then, he sort of gave the song.
It was called "Do the Evolution."
I go, "What's it about?"
He goes, "Oh, it's about all time, space,
and dimension, but you've got to do it in
three and a half minutes."
I go, "Okay, I think we can come up with some
creative things on it."
And then, Eddie went away and he goes, "Here,
I'll send you something here in a couple days
just to sort of give you the vibe."
And so, a couple days later, I receive in
the mail from Eddie this tape and I play it.
He's taken a couple of episodes of Spawn and
edited them to go with his music of the song
that we were talking about, "Do the Evolution."
Tim Ferriss: That must have been surreal.
Todd McFarlane: I wish I had that tape.
I don't know what I did with this tape.
And so I get on the phone, and it was really
good.
I've got to tell you, Tim, it was really good.
I get on the phone, I go, "Oh," I said, "Hey,
Eddie, I've got it.
I understand what you want to do.
Okay, whatever.
We'll come up with that.
Who edited this thing?
This is super cool."
He says, "Oh, that was me."
And I went, "Hold a sec.
You edited this video?"
"Uh-huh."
The big editing machine was called an Avid,
"You have an Avid at home?"
"Yeah, I have an Avid."
"Wow, Eddie, you're confusing me a bit.
Rock and rollers, when they're done off stage,
go home, relax by doing Avid editing?"
It doesn't make any sense to me.
But he's like, "Yeah, I just sort of like
it and it's just sort of therapeutic."
I'm like, "Cool."
We end up doing the video for him and doing
the animation for it.
It ends up getting nominated for a Grammy
which, again, it was my first foray into music.
I went, "What?
You go into music and you get nominated for
a Grammy.
That was easy.
Should have done this earlier."
We lost to Madonna that year.
But we're going to edit and Eddie says, "Hey,
is there any way I can come to California
and edit with you?"
"Eddie, it's your video.
You can do whatever you want.
Sure, heck, come."
He sat with us in the three days that we were
there editing, and he's really smart.
I mean, really, he had a lot of good stuff.
"Hey, what if you did this?
What if you cut this down and you did this,"
and whatever.
He's talking the language.
It was really good.
The side story of that three days was he came
with a briefcase, the first day, and he's
Eddie, all dressed in black.
But he had a briefcase, what I thought was
sort of formal.
He put the briefcase down next to us and then
we worked all day and we did the editing,
and then he left.
And then, the next day he came dressed just
like grunge Eddie, cool.
He had his briefcase again and he put it right
down next to us.
Never touched it the whole day again, and
he left.
And then, on the third day he came, same thing.
But at some point, I just went, "Hey Eddie,
I don't mean to pry, but why do you keep bringing
the briefcase with you every day?
It doesn't seem like you do anything with
it."
And then, he goes, "Oh, my gosh, Todd, I'm
glad you finally asked."
Now, I often wonder if I hadn't asked, what
would've happened?
Would he had just gone home that day?
He goes, "Oh, my gosh, Todd, I'm glad you
finally asked."
It was a briefcase, just like you're a spy
or something.
And then he clicked it open and you're waiting
for the CIA folders, except for there wasn't
no CIA folders, it was two baseball gloves
and a ball.
And one of the gloves was lefthanded.
He turns to me and he goes, "I heard you're
a pretty good baseball player, Todd."
I went, "Yeah, yeah, I played back then, Eddie."
He goes, "You want to play catch during lunch
break?"
I went, "Sure, I can play catch with Eddie
Vedder.
That's cool," because Eddie's a big baseball
nut.
And so he had done his homework and he knew
it and he knew I was left-handed.
Like I said, if I'd never asked him about
it, would he have ever opened it?
But then it goes even further.
We finally go outside and, unfortunately,
it's seasonably hot.
It's about 105, 106 that day in California.
But I'm from Phoenix, it doesn't matter.
I can deal.
But Eddie has got black boots, black pants,
black shirt, black sunglasses, and he's smoking.
Have you ever seen that scene of John Candy
in the movie Splash where he is trying to
play handball and he's drinking and whatever,
and he's having a heart attack while he's
playing?
We start going and, at about minute eight,
I could see he's starting to slow down and
the throws are not quite with the authority
and it gets slower.
And then, he starts breathing heavier.
And then, pretty soon I go, "Eddie, let's
just take a break."
He's like, "Yeah, okay, if you want to."
If you want to.
And then he sits down and he, "Uh, oh."
I mean, I go, "I'm going to kill this man."
We keep playing, he's literally going to pass
out with heat exhaustion, I'm going to have
to rush him to the hospital.
But he wasn't going to give in.
This is a dumb thing about boys and our testosterone.
Neither one of us was going to give, but I'm
a cockroach.
I could have gone all day until I killed him.
I just pulled it back.
I didn't feel like being the guy that was
the one that sent Eddie to the hospital and
had to cancel his — because they were on
tour at that point.
He just came in for a couple days.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, God.
Todd McFarlane: I didn't want to be the bad
guy.
But anyways, Eddie wasn't quite smart enough
to go dress appropriately and don't smoke
when you're exerting yourself physically but,
anyways.
Tim Ferriss: And so that video goes on to,
I don't know how many views it has now on
YouTube, like 50 plus some million views on
YouTube.
We'll link to that in the show notes.
Where does all of this lead?
This is your first foray into music and you're
animating, which means you're directing.
Todd McFarlane: But that comes from the HBO.
Again, this is —
Tim Ferriss: Right, it comes from the HBO.
Todd McFarlane: Right.
Again, you do Marvel, that begat Image Comics.
Image begat — I'm going to use biblical
terms, begat Spawn.
Spawn begat HBO.
HBO, because Eddie was watching it, begat,
"Hey, you want to do a music video?"
Music video comes out successful, gets nominated
for a Grammy, that begat people phoning, "Hey,
you want to do more music videos?"
It all just becomes this weird accident that
just starts tumbling and these doors of opportunity
open up where you never knew they were ever
going to open up before.
None of it's planned.
It's just happy accidents along the way.
Tim Ferriss: And doing a good job on each
piece of it so that those doors open or present
themselves.
Todd McFarlane: So let's talk about that piece.
What you just said is important.
Sometimes I get people go, "Oh, Todd, you're
just sort of getting rich and famous and you
got a ego," whatever else.
Probably that's true.
But let me tell you why I like success.
Not because I want some more money.
I've got it.
Not because I need a bigger ego.
I've got plenty of people who've said nice
things about me for plenty of years.
I'm over me.
Nobody's more bored of Todd than me.
Here's why success matters, because you can't
keep doing art, which is what I am, an artist.
If I walk into the room and say, "Oh, get
this, the last thing I did failed," you don't
get the job.
You have to have a certain level of success
to get the next job.
That's why I need to keep the momentum.
That's why I need to have success.
Not for the fame or the fortune.
That's just a byproduct.
I need it so I can do art again tomorrow and
the next day and the next day.
Hopefully, if I do it right, I'll die and
I'll have been doing art until the time I
take my last breath.
That's the success.
The art and the success has to be a component.
You're not dealing with HBO and the NFL and
Microsoft and all these companies we've dealt
with if you're not able to show that you can
do the job at a level that makes sense for
them.
I'm not going to apologize for us doing our
jobs.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Doesn't seem to be your style.
All right.
We're talking about these multiple encounters
with our very nice friend, dumb luck.
But it's not really, as somebody put it to
me once, I can't remember exactly who it was,
I wish I could give attribution, but they
talk about the surface area of luck.
By doing certain things, you can increase
the surface area that is available for luck
to stick to.
Todd McFarlane: I agree.
Tim Ferriss: I think you've done a very good
job with that.
Where do games or movies enter into this entire
constellation of activities?
Todd McFarlane: Right.
Let's go back to the dumb luck just for a
minute to just paint a metaphor.
Again, I at half court and I got my back to
the basket and I throw it backwards, and then
I make the bucket and they're like, "Oh, Todd,
you're a genius."
Some people will look at that and go, "You're
a genius."
I'm going, "Eh, it's a little bit of dumb
luck."
But to your point, the reason that I was able
to get that genius shot that some people think
of, because I was there for four days in a
row and I took 10,000 shots and I missed every
other one, but I didn't leave until I made
the shot.
If you take 10,000 shots, sometimes one of
them goes in.
There's the personality of going when they
say, "No," which is basically a missed shot,
"Don't do it, Todd."
"Oh, yeah, I'm going to shoot again."
"You can't do that."
"I'm going to shoot again."
"You can't.
You can't."
Shoot, shoot, shoot.
And then, bam, every now and then you sink
one and then you go, "How do I build off that?"
Because people saw that, you put it up on
TikTok and you don't show all of your misses
on all those TikToks.
You only show the one you made.
You don't know how many years or hours or
months they spent until they made that one
shot.
Business, a little bit is like that.
Again, it's a perceived skill because when
you see the one shot on TikTok, you think
they're super awesome because you didn't see
the three days they didn't make it.
There's a little bit of that going on there,
so back to your question, sorry.
Tim Ferriss: Well, actually, before we get
to games and movies and how that sort of coalesced
or entered the scene in some way, let's talk
about creating characters or fictional worlds
that endure for decades.
In doing research for this, I found an interview
of yours where you talked about going into
Hollywood and pitching various ideas.
I might be misquoting, you can't believe everything
you read on the internet, but the section
here that I'd love to hear you elaborate on
is, "So these people in the meeting go, 'What's
the end of it?'
And my answer is "I don't give a shit.
What's the end of Superman?
What's the end of Batman?
What's the end of Spider-Man?
Why are you asking me for the end?
Why aren't you asking, 'Can this last for
30 years?'"
It goes on.
But could you just speak to building something
that endures and how that informs, maybe,
decisions you make or how you think about
creativity?
Todd McFarlane: Well, that quote that you
spoke is true, and I've had that conversation
many, many times in Hollywood.
It's weird that you're walking in, presenting
them the beginning of an idea, and one of
the first questions is, how does the idea
end?
For a company, a studio, a conglomerate, who's
built on trying to make money, why would you
want to kill anything in the crib?
It's a weird conversation I'm having with
them because, again, what is the end of Batman?
I don't know.
Who cares?
We hope it goes a thousand years.
Why are we talking about this in the first
meeting?
I mean, I get it maybe in season three and
the ratings are lagging, we can maybe have
this conversation, but not in the first one.
I think one of the ways to create a brand
that does have some value is using another
word, and it's called attrition.
Attrition is that, over time, you're going
to have both high points and low points, but
you've got to just keep going.
You can't quit.
You've got to just keep going and going and
going and going and find yourself and put
yourself in as many corners as possible, during
both the good and the bad time, so that maybe
people don't know who you are or don't know
what you do but then they go, "You know what?
I've heard the character Spawn."
They don't have to have bought anything.
I'm going to use a big example.
I know and have read nothing about the Kardashians,
and yet I have information in my head about
them.
I've done nothing towards that and, still,
it's in my head.
Why?
Because I can't get away from them.
Somehow, because I'm looking for an article,
I read the headline, and so I've got info.
That's just attrition.
And so, were people going, "Did the Spawn
comic book have a lull at times?"
Of course it did.
Where the sales were not very good?
But I thought that the value wasn't that,
was I making money in the way that I needed
to at that point, it was just to keep the
machinery going because the value, at some
point, isn't now any single issue or any single
year, it's now sum total of all of it.
So that all the people over 30 years who have
passed through any of the characters I've
created, let's use Spawn.
He's my biggest guy.
Maybe they came in for five years and then
quit, but they're still there.
They're still there.
If we ever do a movie, they're going to remember,
"Oh, yeah, yeah.
20 years ago, I collect that."
But maybe it was somebody who passed through
it 15 years ago or 10 years ago, or five years
ago, or just jumped on since we set the world's
record that came in going, "Huh, you know
what?
I've been a DC and Marvel acolyte and now
I'm going to sort of try this."
I don't care.
All you want to do is collectively keep building
so that when you go to your next move, you
can maybe peel off a piece of that army off
to the side.
To me, now, it's just attrition of just going
again, again, again.
And so it will just get into your brain.
I'll give you a bad, bad, bad example early
on.
I mentioned it before when I was at my first
Toy Fair.
I gave them a Hot Wheel.
I bought a funny car.
I don't know if people know what a funny car
is, but a funny car is a cut down dragster
and they put this really cool fiberglass body
and they go down.
Just Google, what's a funny car look like?
They're super cool.
When I grew up in Orange County, Orange County
International Raceway, we used to go down
there, funny cars was the coolest thing in
my life.
Way better than dragons and robots.
Anyways, I bought a funny car when Spawn came
out and, really, because I wanted a funny
car, but I had to convince my wife and other
people otherwise.
It was like, "No, it's not that I need a funny
car, it's just that if I take a funny car
and I paint the word "Spawn" on it and I take
it to shows, you know who has a funny car
at comic book conventions?
No one.
You know who's ever had a funny car comic
book conventions?
No one."
If you bring something to a show that nobody's
ever brought before, you'll be surprised.
If you bring a elephant to a comic book convention
and paint it purple, people will actually
look at it.
They'll come and look at it because they'll
be going, "Why you got a purple elephant here?"
My purple elephant, my pink elephant, literally
was the funny car.
Now, here's what I did.
I did a two tone paint job on it.
One side was white with the word "Spawn" on
it and it had blood like you hit a deer at
a thousand miles an hour and it splattered
over the white.
The other side was black with flames because
it's super cool.
And then, what I used to do, Tim, is I used
to have it sort of centered in my big giant
booth.
And then, I had this piece of paper and it
said, "Vote.
Which side do you like better so I can finish
this project?"
Here's what people did.
I saw it with my own eyes hundreds of times.
They took their kid or one person and they
went on the white side and they went, "Yeah,
that's kind of cool with the blood.
I like it, and I like the fade."
They went over to the flame black side and
went, "Yeah, I like that.
But, man, let me see.
Let me go back over there.
No, maybe I like that one," and it went back
and forth, back and forth.
And then, they marked the sheet.
You know what I did with the sheet at the
end of each show?
I threw it in the garbage.
I didn't give a shit.
I was never going to repaint that car.
What I needed them to do, Tim, was to spend
five minutes looking at my logo.
If I had painted that car with one paint job,
the same on both sides, they wouldn't have
looked at it for five minutes.
I forced them to look at the word "Spawn"
thinking that they were helping me on some
polling survey, and it was just I need to
get the word "Spawn" into their wormhole.
This was my trick.
If you just figure out iterations of that,
how do you get people to do that?
Then eventually, over time, time matters.
Time does matter.
Time becomes the biggest value you have on
your brand.
Tim Ferriss: From a creative, let's just say,
writing standpoint, you've now published more
than 300 editions of Spawn.
When you started Spawn, how many books out
had you planned from a plot or character perspective?
How much of it was setting, conditions and
making it cool, and then assuming you're just
going to figure it out later and see where
it goes?
How far in advance did you or do you plan
with that kind of thing?
Todd McFarlane: Tim, I just finished what's
going to be the biggest comic book in the
country this just last week, the Batman/Spawn
crossover.
We touched upon it.
I was winging it until they pried it out of
my hand on Tuesday.
What are you talking about?
It horrifies writers.
The way that I do it is horrifying.
Do I have it in my head?
Of course not.
I just figure it out on the fly and, luckily,
I get it right more times than I get it wrong.
Here's what the goal was when I started Spawn.
There was two goals.
One, we started the company Image Comics,
the third largest company as I mentioned.
I said to myself, when we started, that Image
Comic Books will exist for my lifetime.
How do I know that?
because even if there was only one book called
Spawn, I was never going to take that logo
off.
I knew it was going to exist because I'm just
that militant.
I'm putting it on issue number one and it
will never come off.
Image Comic Books somehow, maybe in a small
tiny way, will exist.
Obviously, we're flourishing so I don't have
to worry about there only being one book because
we do about 60 or 70 books a month.
Number two, could I create a character that
would outlive me, period.
The guy who created Superman is dead.
The guy who created Mickey Mouse, dead.
The guy who created the Fantastic Four, we
talked about him earlier today, Stan Lee,
dead.
Their characters live on.
I consider creations to be creative children.
Every parent has the same wish.
You always want your children to outlive you.
Why?
No parent gets up saying, "I hope my children
go before I do."
You always want to go.
We've seen movies, "I'll sacrifice my life.
Women and children first."
You'll sacrifice your life for your family,
but you go first.
If these are creative children, then the goal
is, because I read about these people who
created these characters that I know about,
but their creators have long since passed
away, including my good friend Stan.
Could I create one or two characters?
I don't need a hundred.
I'm not Disney.
I'm not Walt Disney.
I'm not Stan Lee.
I'm not that good.
But could I create one or two characters that
when I die, people say, "I still want to see
the characters."
That was the goal in the back of my head.
Did I have a plan of where it was going?
No, not really.
Did I have a plan of how it was going to end?
I do actually have the end.
I just never have given it to anybody, and
I hope it never gets written, because the
only time you write the end is if nobody wants
it.
So you go, "Ah, I guess we better write the
last story and put it to bed," or whatever
else.
Now to the point, Tim, and I hate saying this
out loud, but Spawn's costume was alive.
It's like a symbiot.
It moves, and the chains are like the tongue,
and the spikes are like the teeth, and the
cape is all alive.
Was his costume alive an issue with number
one?
No.
How did it become alive?
You just hit these moments real quickly.
People were right in, because I'm very lazy.
I never did a lot of referencing.
There was no internet, but I still didn't
go to the library and get reference.
I had deadlines, don't have time for it.
I just fake everything.
So I was drawing my pages of issue number
one, and I guess this is how bad I am.
I don't pay attention to my own drawings.
People were writing in, going, "Todd Todd,
do you know you had the pouch on his left
leg, and now it's on his right leg?
Do you know that you had six spikes on his
arm, and now he's got eight spikes?"
These are easy moments, Tim, that you have
two choices.
You either admit you're a dumb shit.
Or you go, "That's because it's alive.
The costume morphs, and it can do anything
at any time.
It's a living being."
And that's now part of the mythology, and
it was just because I screwed up.
What are you talking about?
You make lemonade out of your lemons, and
you just keep moving on and hope they don't
catch up to you.
I've been in those rooms plenty of times,
where I said something I shouldn't have, and
they go —
I'll give you an example.
I was doing a movie pitch for something, and
I think it was for Doom or something.
I was given this pitch, and they discovered
something underneath the Mojave Desert or
whatever.
I was on a rant, and my buddy next to me slides
a piece of paper over to me.
I'm right in the middle of it.
I'm with the Warner Bros. people and the prior
writers, because they brought me in to see
if they could help spark it.
He slides a piece of paper over to me as I'm
standing up, and on it says, "Todd, it takes
place on the moon," or something like that.
I'm going, "And they discover it in the Mojave
Desert."
I'm actually off a lot of miles, and I'm like
—
So I just blow the whole premise of this book,
and I'd go, "Well, I'm this deep.
I've got to finish.
I've got to keep going."
And I sit down, and I remember the executive
at Warner Bros. looks at me for a couple seconds,
dead silence.
And then he goes, slaps his hand and goes,
"That's what I'm talking about.
He's not afraid to take chances!
He's not afraid."
And the answer was, I just didn't do enough
research, sadly.
Otherwise, I would've put it on the moon.
So sometimes you just have to, if you say
it with enough confidence, they'll go along
for the ride with it.
"He's not afraid to basically follow everything
in the book.
This is what I've been talking about.
We've got to bend some of the rules, blah,
blah blah."
Anyways, The Spawn, we're up to issue 336.
Went to the printers a couple days ago.
Do I know what 337 is?
I write a book called Gunslinger Spawn.
Do I know what the next issue is?
Nope.
I know there's a guy.
I just introduced a cliffhanger with a guy
who runs fast.
That's all I know, that I've got to pick up
with a guy who runs fast.
So I'll figure it out when I've got to get
the plot in two days.
10 years from now, you and I may be talking
about my speedster runner, who's the most
popular guy.
I had no idea the day before what I was doing
with him.
Tim Ferriss: Well, Todd, where do you want
to go next?
I'll leave it up to you.
You've got so many stories.
You seemingly have so many lives that run
in tandem.
You're an excellent five-ball juggler.
Which ball, if any, would you like to talk
about next?
Todd McFarlane: What if we get away from the
businesses and talk about personalities, not
mine, but other people.
I think that what's of value to people who
are thinking about doing ideas and/or some
entrepreneurialship is, to some extent, recognizing
your own personalities of whether you're actually
built for war or not.
To me, all of this is a war.
I know my wife has said, "It's sort of sad
that you see your life as a war every day."
I'm ready, and if I've got one regret, and
I've got a few of them, but one of them is
I wish I was born 3,000 years ago, because
back then, in a movie like Braveheart, if
you believed in something so strongly, you
would go to the battlefield.
You would face your enemy, who basically was
trying to deny you whatever it was that would
give you personal happiness or what you thought
would be good for your family.
Only two things were going to happen.
You were either going to cut his head off,
or he was going to cut yours.
That simple.
I've always been the guy willing to go, "I'll
die for what I believe."
Now, unfortunately, Tim, killing your enemy
and cutting their head off is illegal.
It's really frustrating to me because man,
there's a lot of heads I'd like to see on
the ground.
And I'm sure they'd like to see mine.
But we can't do that.
We have to be a law-abiding citizen.
So now what we have to do in modern times
is sue people and take away market shares
and tell them "You will never work in this
town."
And it's just not nearly as satisfying as
if I could just cut their heads off.
If I get ready for the war, which means that
every day — I'm going to give you a piece
of advice that don't tell your mom if you're
listening to me, because moms will be horrified
by this — here it is: lower the bar.
Lower the bar.
Don't raise the bar.
Lower it.
Here's why.
Way easier to get over low bars than it is
high bars.
Try it.
Put a bar six feet high, try to jump over
it.
Put a bar six inches off the ground.
You can get over it 20 times in a minute.
It's easy.
Lower the bar, ladies and gentlemen.
That means that I get up every day, and I
don't have high expectations of anything,
not even with humanity.
I'm not a religious person, but I do have
a personal prayer, and it's this simple, every
day: "Today will not be perfect."
And many days in a row, Tim, I've nailed that.
Every single day of my life I have never — I'm
on even a longer streak than Cal Ripken Jr.
with that.
What tortures people, and some of you are
listening, are the people who have the bar
higher than that.
"Did you see this email this guy sent me?
That son of a bitch."
"Oh, you thought today was going to be perfect.
Did you see that guy?
That guy cut me off on the freeway."
"Oh, that guy cut me off here in line.
I was waiting in line, and they cut me off
getting a ticket for the Black Panther movie,
and now I can't get in," or whatever.
"Oh, somebody said something about my haircut."
"Somebody said something about that."
So you thought that the world was going to
be perfect and that everybody was going to
wake up and that they were going to make your
life better.
You know who woke up on the planet today with
eight billion people and said, "I'm going
to make Todd's life better today?"
There was only one human being — one — and
that was me.
No other human being, not even my wife, that
was their mission today.
That was me.
So if you're expecting others to make you
happy and make it accommodating for you, you're
going to get crushed.
Here's what I would say.
Lower the bar.
Go to your job interview, and before you walk
in, give it your damnedest, but assume you're
not getting the job.
Give it your damnedest, but assume you're
not getting it.
So when they don't phone you back, and when
you don't get the job, you are okay with it,
because if anything, you actually take it
as a pride that you actually called the shot.
"I knew it, I knew it.
I went there.
They didn't give it to me.
Dumb shit, but I knew it."
And pretty soon you don't get hired for 10,
20 jobs in a row, and you're on a hot streak
now.
You're actually feeling pretty good that you
called it 20 times in a row, you're not getting
the job.
And then guess what happens?
You go to the 21st interview, and you give
it your best, and you walk away and they go,
"Todd, where are you going?"
"I'm out of here because I know you're not
going to hire me."
And they go, "No, we actually want to offer
you a job."
And here's why that's a awesome day, because
well, it's sort of quasi-frustrated.
First off, they break my streak of 20 noes
in a row.
So I'm a little frustrated that my streak
went away, because I'm like, "God damn it,
they broke my streak."
But by breaking my streak, I got the job.
I got the job.
It's a good day.
Here's what most people do, Tim, and my family
members do the same thing.
And I can't help if it's a personality.
They actually think they're going to get every
job they go and apply for.
And when they don't, they get crushed.
It literally crushes their soul for two or
three days, and they're a shell of a person.
Why?
Because they put the bar high.
The bar was that we were going to get the
job.
No, put the bar where it says, "I'm not getting
the job," and you will never be disappointed.
Assume today's not going to be perfect and
assume human beings are flawed, and you will
have a pretty good life.
Because guess what happens?
Some days, nobody cuts you off, nobody cuts
in line, and nobody writes you a bad email.
And it's a pretty good day.
It's a pretty good day because discomfort
didn't come.
Not that you won the lottery, not that your
team won the championship.
You just didn't have a lot of aggravation.
You didn't get sued today.
Cool.
It's a good day.
I don't know.
I psych myself out.
I psych myself out for little success, so
when any of it comes, it's cool.
We talked about it with selling the toys at
60,000.
There's either way to get to 60,000 sales,
and it be a negative, or it can be a positive.
It depends on how you psych yourself out.
I am a horrible golfer, horrible golfer.
I don't do it much.
Also, I've had people say, "Todd, you're the
worst golfer who doesn't care."
Here's why I don't care.
I don't golf, and so I don't golf.
I don't assume I'm going to get better by
not golfing every three years, any more than
my Mandarin and my Spanish is going to get
better by me not practicing either one of
those languages either.
You don't get better by not doing it.
So when I go golf, the odd time I'm in Phoenix,
I'm horrible.
But every now and then, I get lucky, and all
of a sudden, on a par five, I get a six.
I am dancing naked when I get a six on a par
five.
But it's interesting.
I'm with another guy who must have had a different
expectation.
His bar was different than mine.
He hits it, he hits it, he gets a six.
And he is so mad, he actually breaks his club
that costs more than my entire rental.
And he breaks his club, and I'm sitting there
going, "Wow, he got a six.
I got a six.
It's the same number.
I'm dancing naked, and he's cursing up a storm.
He must have had a different expectation than
me."
So that's it.
I just keep my expectations low.
It gets you through there.
Number two, they're always going to say no
to you, always going to say no to you.
There has never been a story written in which
the person who had the new idea, the person
in the lead said, "Oh, I will now slow down
or get out of the way so you can pass me."
Never ever will happen.
So if you're going to do something that's
going to aggravate the system status quo,
there's never been anybody in history that's
ever changed anything on any level and was
liked by everybody.
Get over it.
Get over people liking you.
Just figure out what your goal is.
I'll give you my personality.
I take my wife.
We're going to go to the bar, and we're going
to go dance.
Okay.
Nine o'clock comes around, the band starts
playing, nobody wants to be the first one
on the dance floor.
Let me also say, if you've never been the
first one on a dance floor, you're probably
not built to be an entrepreneur.
Let me just put that there, because that means
you give a shit about the rest of the people
in that room.
I don't.
And here's why.
First off, I don't even know them.
Why would I give any weight, why would I give
any power to a stranger in my life?
Here's what my goal is.
My goal was to take my lovely wife out for
an evening of dancing.
There's a dance floor, and there's music.
I'm going to dance.
If every other human being in that room doesn't
want to dance, I don't care.
If they all want to dance, I don't care.
None of them are of importance to me.
What's important is that I want to dance with
my wife tonight, and I'm doing it.
I'm doing it.
Do I care whether they think I'm a good dancer?
Nope.
Do I care if they think I look like a goof?
Not one second of power do I give to that
person.
If you are the person that's going to wait
till the dance floor is full so that then
you can get on and nobody will see you so
you can hide in the middle of the pack, I'm
just telling you, you're probably not built
to be an entrepreneur.
You have to just be at times, literally, don't
care.
It's not a trait that I want to encourage.
I don't want my kids to be like me.
But you have to have it, because if you're
going to make change, if you're going to go
up against competition, they're going to,
every day, try and tell you you can't and
try and embarrass you somehow.
And you have to just push it and categorize
it to a side and say, "I don't care.
This was my goal, and I'm going to do it anyways."
Tim Ferriss: Now, why would you not want your
kids to have that trait?
What's the downside?
Or how do you think about that?
Todd McFarlane: Because I can be a cold fish
at times.
When you —
Tim Ferriss: Cold fish.
Todd McFarlane: Right.
Tim Ferriss: Meaning you're like too Spock-like,
or you come off as unemotional?
Todd McFarlane: No, no.
I told you.
Let's say you put me out tomorrow, and I could
cut the heads of my enemy though.
Let's go back to Braveheart.
And I could cut the heads of my enemy.
So I got my mortal enemy in front of me, and
I cut his head off.
Do you know how much time I'm going to give
to feeling guilty that I did it?
Zero seconds.
You know why, Tim?
Because I'm in the middle of a battle.
Remember, I keep thinking I'm at war.
And if you watch something like Braveheart,
I'm not the only one, and they're not the
only one on the battlefield.
And if I sit there and give time to feel sorry
for what I did to that man and think about
his family and his children, somebody coming
up behind me is going to cut my head off,
and I will be dead six seconds later.
So I must learn to cut and turn and forget
about that dead victim, because somebody's
out to kill me five seconds later, and I either
survive, or at least attempt to survive, or
I lament and get my head cut off in a second.
Here's how this works, Tim, here's how this
works in practical, modern terms for a guy
like Todd.
And I don't necessarily want anybody to do
it.
I'm just telling you who I am.
I usually phone lawyers that I don't like,
and I'm in a fight with on Friday about 4:30.
This is actually a very good time, and here's
why it's a good time.
Because I can get on the phone with them,
and they can argue.
And then you start raising voices, and you
start sounding like Mussolini on the balcony.
And you start going, and then you usually
end those conversations like, "Oh, yeah?
Well, fuck you."
"Yeah, well, fuck you."
"Okay, I'll get on the phone with you Monday.
We're going to settle this bullshit."
And you go "Click."
Now, here's what I've told my wife, because
she's heard me do this before.
She goes, "Todd."
She's heard me before.
"Todd, you're going to have a heart attack."
"No, I'm not."
"Yes, you're going to have a heart attack."
"No, I'm not.
And here's why."
My wife's name is Wanda.
"No, Wanda, I'm not going to have a heart
attack."
And she doesn't believe this, until this one
scary moment, that I go, "No."
And she goes, "Why?"
I go, "Because I don't care."
The moment I hang up that phone, click, I
don't even care about that guy.
That lawyer I just yelled at?
Click.
He's like, "Dude.
The weekend's coming.
I'll worry about him on Monday.
I'll worry about him on Monday."
But because I can do that, here's what happens
to the lawyer.
He gets off the phone.
He goes to all of his people in the office,
he goes, "I just got off the phone with this
son of a bitch, and here's what he said."
And he's going to chew on it, and he's going
to chew on it.
Then he's going to go home, and his wife's
going to say, "How was your day?"
"Oh, fine, except for at the end, this guy..."
And he's going to chew on it.
And then they're going to go out, and they're
going to have a barbecue with their friends.
They're going to go, "How are things going?"
"Oh, fine, but I've got this one thing."
And he's going to chew on it and chew on it.
And he's going to sit there and think about
me the whole weekend.
By Monday, he's exhausted.
And you know how much time I gave him during
that same amount of time?
Not one second of my emotions.
Why?
Because on Monday, click, I turn it back on.
Guess, between the two of us, who's emotionally
more stronger to continue the conversation?
The guy who was in the gym the whole time,
bench pressing that weight?
Or the guy who put it down and let his muscle
sort of relax so I can go back to the gym
a couple days later?
I don't care.
And here's how I know that's true.
I know it's true.
You can believe it or not, but I proved it
to my wife one day.
She took out a life insurance policy or something,
and the doctors have to come to the house,
and they have to do an exam on you to make
sure that you're not dying or whatever.
They come, and they got to do an examination
on me and my wife.
My wife is top fit.
She's awesome.
She is a hiker, runner.
She's like a model.
She's awesome.
Anyways, they came, and I was in the middle
of one of these Mussolini moments.
The doctors came, and they go, "Todd, we've
got to examine you."
And I go, "Tell them to do Wanda first.
I'm on the phone, I'm on the phone."
They go and do Wanda.
And then, they do my wife, whatever they had
to do.
And then, they come upstairs.
She knows.
She can still hear me yelling.
She comes up with the doctors, there's a couple
of them, and then they go, "Okay, Todd, it's
you."
And I go, "Yeah, oh, yeah, okay.
And fuck you."
Click.
I end my conversation.
I go, "What are we doing?
Oh, we've got to do this examination.
Oh, yeah, okay.
Cool."
My wife was waiting for it.
They do the blood pressure, and they do all
the testing.
And they go, "Oh, yours is the same as your
wife's."
I literally, and it horrified my wife, let
me just tell you it horrified her, because
she goes, "I am married."
A, she was happy that I'm not going to die
of a heart attack, because I literally can
turn the switch off.
Two, she was horrified she's married to a
monster, that he literally doesn't care about
another human being and can just turn it off.
I turn it off, Tim, not out of pride, not
because I think that's the way to go, not
because I think that's it.
It's because we all, if you're in war, and
I think I'm in war, if you're at war, you
have to find out ways of surviving that work
for you.
This is how I've learned to survive, to not
let any — I've been sued, I've been screamed
at.
I've had people threatened.
The other day, what are you talking about?
One of the big retailers threatened to take
all my toys off their shelf.
You just accept that this is just part of
the world that you live in.
If at any time, Tim, I ever get aggravated
— you know who I'm the most aggravated with?
Me, because at the end, no matter what's happening,
I have to ask the same question.
"Who put me in this position?"
"It's uncomfortable.
I don't want be here.
Why am I arguing with lawyers today?
Oh, that was you, Todd.
You started that company.
You kept it going.
You kept doing it."
I don't get to pass the buck.
I have to sit there and say, "The guy who
basically caused all this is the guy I shave
with every day."
And here's the problem with that.
I actually like that dude.
And even if I don't, I've got to live with
him for the rest of my natural life.
So you know what?
I'm stuck.
I'm stuck with it.
I just figure out ways that work for me.
I don't want you or any listener to replicate
it.
I would say, "No."
What I do do when I go to business classes,
which is super awesome, when I go talk to
business classes at university, first thing
I say is, "I'm not going to tell you how to
make money."
85 percent of them throw their pencil down
in disgust, because they thought I was going
to give them the 10 lessons in how to make
money.
I go, "Here's what we're going to talk about
for an hour: how to keep your humanity, how
to actually be a reasonable human being.
So here's what I'm going to tell you.
I would rather you become a garbage collector
and go become a good community person and
go coach Little League for free than to be
the VP of a bank and be divorced four times
and estranged from your family and nobody
wants to hang out with you."
We somehow equate, in North America, money
to success.
And to me, my definition of success is different.
I just think that there's a way to just not
care, even if you do have money and prestige
and all of it.
To me, it's all silly.
It's all complicated our lives.
My wife will tell you the same.
It was easier when life was simpler.
But you guys are built, the guys that are
doing their MBAs in these classes, they're
just little baby sharks.
When I'm giving that conversation, I know
that they want to emulate the big sharks,
so I'm only talking to four or five of them
that are out there.
And at the end of it, after we go with it,
I sometimes do this last little question there.
I go, "I'm just going to leave you with one
thing, because I know about making money.
You've got to make money.
And the reason I don't want to tell you how
to make money, because if I tell you how to
make a million bucks, you, in your brain and
your intellect and your personal experiences,
might have figured out how to make a hundred
million.
Why would I try to tell you how to make a
million?
You might have made a hundred million.
You may be a thousand times smarter than me.
I don't want to limit you.
But let me just leave — once we talked all
of this to see if we can't leave you with
one thought here.
All of you just woke up tomorrow, and you're
not feeling very good, so you go to the doctor.
Doctor takes you in the back room, and he
does a bunch of blood tests and says, 'Hey,
I'm going to run the blood test.'
And you go sit out in the lobby.
'I'll get back to you.'
"So you go out in the lobby, and you look
on your cell phone for a while.
25 minutes later the doctor comes back.
He doesn't look very good.
He's got a serious look.
And he says, 'Hey, I need you to come back
to my office.'
'Yeah, sure, doc.'
"You go sit down.
They go, 'We ran all the tests, and we reran
them, and you have inoperable cancer.
There is nothing modern medicine can do.
You will be dead in three weeks.
You're dead.
There's no hope.'
“Now, I'm going to assume that everybody
listening to my voice right now has at least
one person they care about, at least one person.
So think about the person that you care about
the most.
That person, I assume if you care for them
that much, they care about you that much.
And in three weeks that person is going to
be left without you.
It will be trauma to their life.
“So here's the question.
If you could only pick one human being to
help that person you care about to transition
after you're gone, to soft-land them as much
as possible, to be by their side, to do anything
that will be helpful in their grieving period,
who is that individual?
I want you to pick just one individual.
I'll give you 15 seconds to think of it.”
And then I stand there, Tim, in silence.
And then I go, "My last question before I
leave.
Did you pick the richest person you know,
or did you pick the best person?
Why don't you want to be the second one?
Why don't you want to be the best person instead
of the richest?
Because when it mattered, and we just proved
it, you didn't pick the rich person.
Be the second person, and you can still make
money and be that second person.
Don't worry about it, but don't make the money
the driver.
Don't do it.
But I'm only talking to three of you in this
class.
The rest of you've already sold your soul."
Tim Ferriss: Well, Todd, I think that is the
best place to maybe bring this conversation
home and leave people with that to chew on,
without adding too much more.
I have to say we could easily do a round three
at some point.
But I do think that is an excellent place
to stop and begin to at least land the plane.
Is there anything else that you would like
to add, call people's attention to, or anything
else?
Any closing comments before we end this conversation,
at least for now?
Todd McFarlane: Yeah.
The only thing I'd like to do is encourage
people who have a little bit of doubt.
If you got a lot of bit of doubt, it might
not work.
A little bit of doubt, I think we can get
past that hurdle.
I don't consider myself to be smart or intelligent
or do anything better than anybody else.
I was able, through just a little bit of perseverance,
to get there.
I believe that if I can do it, and I was dumb,
I got nothing but Ds in school and stuff like
that.
If I can do it, I just think there are so
many people up there.
What I do at times, it's frustrating to me.
I'm up on stage sometimes at comic conventions.
I don't even talk about comic books, but I
go, "I'm going to talk to you as your dad,
as your uncle.
And I'm going to tell you why I think you
should try this."
I think we've spoken about some of those on
your show in these two parts.
"Just try it, and if it doesn't work, it's
like cutting your hair.
It'll grow back.
You can always go back to the system wherever
you're at.
You can always go back.
There's no harm, there's no dishonesty in
trying and failing.
That's okay.
The person who never tries, I think, has more
regret."
I talk to them.
I stand on one side of the stage and I go,
"Come on, man.
Just try.
Try.
Try it once."
I think everybody, in all honesty, Tim, should
try to be an entrepreneur once in their life.
And then I walk to the other stage, and I
go, "Now I'm going to talk to you as Todd
the CEO.
And here's what I'm going to tell you as Todd
I hope you don't do it.
I hope you sow those doubts, and you never
do it.
And you know why?
Because that means I will never have to compete
with you.
And you may be smarter and better and more
well-equipped, and I'll never have to play
the game against you.
So make my life easy, and don't compete."
But I'm telling you, the dad side of me?
Take me down.
Man, because the 25-year-old Todd, I'm telling
you, I just know would've listened to me,
the 60-year-old man and would've said, "Dude,
I will gut you."
I would never have let an old man on that
stage go, "I hope you don't do it because
you're not good enough."
I would've gone and said, "Oh, yeah, I've
made it my personal mission."
So even if I can just gin up a couple of people
to just go, "Come on, man.
Come on, man."
You can do it.
But if you keep coming up with reasons why
you're not built for entrepreneurialship,
you have to think a little bit delusional
at times, to the point where you think you're
better than you are.
That's okay.
Confidence is half the battle, and now we've
got to figure out whether you got the skill
set, which is the other half.
But some of the skill can come along the way,
because confidence and determination can take
you pretty far until you learn those skills.
Just go, go, go.
That's all I've got.
Tim Ferriss: Well done.
I will say first that I can see why the people
from the NHL or wherever would've said, "Yeah,
I think we'll just take the 500 grand and
not choose to have this guy jabbing us with
a spear for the next 20 years.
So let's just do that deal."
I can definitely see that.
I find you to be extremely impressive as a
creator, as an artist, fascinating as a CEO.
And I got to say, you're a Hell of a good
teacher.
You're a really good teacher.
So thank you for taking the time to have these
conversations and to share your stories and
your lessons and your beliefs.
It's been a Hell of a lot of fun.
To everybody listening, we will have links
to everything we discussed, all the music
videos, anything else that my team and I can
possibly find as a reference to link to related
to the show, we'll include in the show notes,
including the show notes at tim.blog/podcast.
As usual, you can find Todd on all the social
networks.
We'll link to those in the show notes as well
at tim.blog/podcast.
Until next time, get out there.
Give it a shot.
Take your shot.
You'll miss all of the shots you don't take,
so give it a go.
You can always go back to the system
and
the status quo.
And thanks for listening.